hi everyone
welcome to this video tutorial on python
data analysis project for 2022. in this
video we'll be covering two interesting
hands-on projects using python
programming you will learn how to use
real-world data to perform data analysis
and data visualization the two projects
are based on coronavirus and olympics
data you will learn to collect analyze
clean manipulate and visualize data with
the help of python libraries such as
numpy pandas matplotlib and cbon these
two projects will give you the idea to
solve real world problems using
exploratory data analysis so let's get
started with our first project
today we are going to perform two
hands-on projects on covet data analysis
using python and tableau this is going
to be a really interesting and fun
session where i'll be asking you a few
generic quiz questions related to
coronavirus please make sure to answer
them in the comment section of the video
we'll be happy to hear from you covet or
coronavirus is an ongoing global
pandemic of coronavirus disease that
emerged in 2019 and was first identified
in wuhan china
it is defined as an illness caused by a
novel coronavirus called severe acute
respiratory syndrome coronavirus 2
commonly known as sars cove 2.
on march 11 2020 the who declared coven
19 a global health emergency
the virus has so far infected over 22
crore people and killed more than 4.5
million innocents
in india there have been over 3.3 crore
confirmed cases and nearly 4 lakh 41 000
deaths have been reported so far
this data is according to official
figures released by the union ministry
of health and family welfare
as the world tries to cope up with this
deadly virus we request all our viewers
and their family members to follow all
the necessary precautions to avoid
getting infected
quiz time
now let's see our first quiz in this
project
what does corona in corona virus mean
here are the options is it a beer
b respiratory is it c crown or is it d
sun
this is a very generic question
i'm sure a lot of you may already know
some of you may not
please let us know your answers in the
comment section of the video we'll be
glad to hear from you
now in this video we will use
three different coven 19 data sets and
perform data analysis using python and
tableau
the project will give you hands-on
experience working on real-world data
sets and how you can use the different
python libraries to analyze and
visualize data and draw conclusions
you will learn how to create different
plots in tableau and then make a
dashboard from the visuals the project
will give you an idea about the impact
of coronavirus globally in terms of
confirmed cases deaths reported
the number of recoveries as well as
active cases
we will also see how india has been
affected since the pandemic started and
dive into the different states and union
territories to learn more about the
covet 19 influence and the vaccination
status
first let me show you the two data sets
that we'll be using
so for our first project using python
we'll be using the first two data sets
kovid 19 india and covet vaccine
statewide
let me open the two data sets
okay
so this is the first data set you can
see here
we have
the date
we have the time
then we have the different state names
scroll down you can see we have kerala
tamil nadu delhi haryana rajasthan
punjab
telangana and other states
then we have something called as
confirmed indian national so actually
this
two data sets confirmed indian national
and confirmed foreign national we won't
be using so in the demo itself we'll be
dropping these two columns
what we are concerned about are the last
three columns
the
cured cases or the recoveries
the number of deaths reported and then
we have the
total number of confirmed cases
let me just
sort the b column that is the date
column so that you have an idea
about the recent data we have
i'll continue with the current selection
and
sort it you can see here
this is
till
11th of august 2021
so this data was collected from kegel it
has some discrepancies that we will see
in the demo the data is available for
free
we will provide the link to the data
sets in the description of the video so
please go ahead and download them
the visualizations and results that you
will see in the demo are based on the
data sets that we'll be using we haven't
preprocessed the data to remove outliers
or any missing values
now before i jump into the demo let me
show you the second data set that we are
going to use
okay so covet vaccine statewise is my
second data set
let me open it
there you go
so
this is the second data set that we'll
be using in the python
project you can see we have a column
called updated on then we have the
state again you can see here there are a
few discrepancies here
it has taken the country name and not
the state name below you can see there
are the
different state names
and
you can also see we have information
about the total doses administered
we have the sessions sites
first dose administered then we have the
second dose
then we have information about male and
female doses
you can see here the different
vaccines
administered covaxian and cova shield
you have sputnik v
and here are the different age groups as
well and finally if you see we have
male individuals vaccinated the total
number of female individuals vaccinated
for a particular day
we have information about transgender
individuals vaccinated and finally we
have the total individuals vaccinated
each day
all right before we jump into the
hands-on part let's have a look at the
second quiz in this project
so
here is the second quiz question
which is the first country to start
covet vaccination for toddlers
is it a japan
b israel c portugal or is it d cuba
this is a very recent development that
took place if you watch daily news
updates on coronavirus you will be
definitely able to answer the question
please give it a try and put your
answers in the comments section of the
video it is really important for our
viewers to know the right answer
all right
so now let's begin
with our demo
so i am on my jupyter notebook
so the first project we are going to use
python jupyter notebook
i'll just
rename this notebook as
kovid
data analysis
project
click on rename
all right
so first and foremost
we need to import all the necessary
libraries that we are going to use so
first i am importing pandas as pd this
is for
data manipulation
then we have numpy as np
numpy is used for numerical computation
then we are importing
matplotlib c born and plotly
these three libraries will be used for
plotting our data and creating
interesting visualizations finally i'm
also importing
my datetime
function
all right so i'll hit shift enter to run
the first cell
now it's time
to load our first data set
which is related to
the kovid19 cases in india for the
different states and union territories
so i'll create a variable called covet
underscore df dfs for data frame
i'll use my pandas library
and then
give the read underscore csv function
since our data sets are
csv files
and inside
double quotes i will pass in the
location where my
data sets are present
so i'll just copy this location
i'll paste it here
we'll change
the backslash to forward slash
and after that i'm going to give my file
name followed by the extension of the
file
i'll say kovaid 19
india dot csv
let's go ahead and run it all right
now
to see the first few
rows
of the data frame i'm going to use the
head function
i'll say head and within
brackets let's say i
pass in 10 which means i want to see the
first 10 rows of data
if i run it there you go
here you can see from 0
till 9 so we have 10 rows of information
and these are the different
column names you have s number
date time state or union territory then
you have confirmed indian national
confirmed foreign national
cured cases debts reported and the
confirmed cases
all right
now moving ahead
let's use the
info function to get some idea about
a data set
if i run it you can see here
it gives us the
total number of columns we have nine
columns
the total number of entries or the rows
we have eighteen thousand hundred and
ten rows of information starting from
zero till
eighteen thousand 18109
you see here the different types of
variables or column names that we have
then it has information about the memory
usage as well
and this side you can see
the data types
cool
now we'll use another very important
function which is
to get
some idea about statistical analysis the
basic statistics about your data set for
that i will be using the describe
function
okay
so if you can see here
the describe function is for
numerical columns only and you have the
measures such as count the mean standard
deviation
maximum minimum the
25th percentile 50th percentile and the
75th percentile value
okay
now let's move ahead and import the
second data set
which is related to
vaccination
so i'll create a variable called vaccine
underscore df
i'll write pd dot
read underscore csv function which is
present in pandas
library i'll move to the top and i'll
copy the
file location
and we'll change the name of the file
copy this and
let me paste it here
and instead of covid underscore 19
underscore india
i'm going to say govet
underscore
vaccine
underscore
statewide
okay
so this is the data set that we saw
covered underscore vaccine underscore
statewide
right
let me run it
cool
and
let's display the first
seven rows of information from this data
frame
i'll be using the head function and
inside the function i'll pass in 7
there you go so here you can see we have
from 0 till 6 there are total
24 columns
a lot of them have null values you can
see here
all right
now
from the first data set which is the
kovid underscore df data frame we'll be
dropping a few
unnecessary
columns such as the time column
confirmed indian national and confirmed
foreign national as well as the s number
we don't need these columns so it's
better
to learn how to drop the columns for our
analysis
so i'll say
covid underscore df
dot
i'll use the drop function
and within square brackets i'll pass in
the
column names the first is s number
i'll give a comma
within double quotes i'll say the next
column is time
my third column that i want to drop is
confirmed
indian national
give another comma
within double quotes i'll say
confirmed
foreign national
outside the
square brackets i'll give another comma
and pass in my next
argument
that is in place equal to i'll say true
i'll give another comma and say
axis
equal to 1
let's run it
okay it has thrown an error let's debug
the error
says confirmed indian okay it should be
indian national and not indian nation
i'll just
mention it as national will run it again
okay
now we have
removed these four columns
let me show you the data set now
there you go
so we have only the date column state or
union territory cured that's and
confirmed
now
let's see how you can change the format
of the
date column for that you have the
function called to datetime
i'll say
covid underscore df
i'll pass in my column name that is date
i'll say equal to
pd dot
i'll use the pandas function that is to
underscore
date time
i'll say covered underscore df which is
my data frame name
pass in my
variable which is date
give a comma
and i'll use my argument that is format
equal to
i'll say percentage y
give a dash say percentage
give another dash and say percentage d
let's run it
and i'll print
the head of the data frame
cool now moving ahead
now we will see how to
find the total number of active cases
so active case is nothing but the total
number of confirmed cases minus the sum
of
cure cases plus that's reported
so let's
find the active cases i'll give a
comment
okay
i'll first write my
data frame name that is covered
underscore df
within square brackets i'll give my new
column which is active underscore
cases
i'll say equal to
covered underscore df
and my first column would be
the confirmed cases column
minus
i'll say kuvid underscore df
then i'll pass in my cured column
plus
i'll again say
kovid
underscore df
and
add my
deaths column
this time let's print
the last
five rows from the new
data frame that we have created
okay
let's run it
it has thrown an error let's debug it
says
data frame object has no attribute tails
this should be
teal
there you go
you can see here we have added a new
column called active cases which is
the confirmed cases minus the sum of
cured end
death's reported column
now we will learn how to create a pivot
table using the pandas
library
so in this table we'll be
summing all the
confirmed deaths and cured
cases
for each of the states and union
territories
so we'll be using the pivot underscore
table function for this
i'll create a variable called statewise
and say pd dot
i'll use the pivot underscore table
function
i'll pass in my
data frame that is covet underscore df
and then
i'll give my
values parameter
inside the square brackets i'll pass in
my
columns
confirmed
deaths
and then we'll have the
cured column
give a comma
and next
argument would be index
which is going to be my state
slash
the union territory column
let me bring this to the next line so it
is more readable
i'll say union territory
i will
give a comma now
and pass in my last argument which is
agg
function that means aggregate function
and
this function would be max
all right
let's run it
okay
now
i'm going to find out the
recovery rate
so recovery rate is
basically the total number of qr cases
divided by the total number of confirmed
cases into 100.
so i'll say
statewise
and within square brackets i'll
pass in my
variable that i want to create which is
recovery rate
this will be equal to
[Music]
the
cured cases
multiplied by 100
by the total number of
confirm cases
within square brackets i'll give my
column as confirmed
let's run this
okay
i'll just copy this column
paste it here so this time we are going
to find out the mortality rate
so mortality rate is nothing but the
total number of deaths divided by the
total number of confirmed cases into 100
so i am just going to
replace the
names here i'll say
mortality
all right
and then instead of cured i'll say
my deaths column
into 100 divided by the confirmed cases
let's run it
okay
now
we are going to
sort the values
based on the confirmed cases column
and we'll sort it in descending order so
let me show you how to do it i'll say
statewide equal to
i'll use the function short underscore
values
so
i'll pass in my variable statewise dot
and use the
short underscore
values function i'll say by
i want to sort it by my confirmed
cases column
give a comma and i'll say
ascending
equal
to false
let's run it
now we are going to plot our pivot table
using a nice
visual so for that i'm going to use
my
background underscore gradient function
and inside that function we'll pass in
our c map parameter
i'll show you how to do it
style dot
background
underscore
gradient
and inside this will pass in a parameter
called cmap
so cmap stands for color maps this is
present inside the matplotlib library so
here you can see there's a nice
documentation on choosing color maps in
matplotlib
this is provided by matplotlib.org
if i scroll down you can see there are
a number of c maps that you can use
purples blues
you have something called reds
there are other things like magma you
have summer autumn spring winter
cool
all these
you can use whichever color map that you
want and here you can see the different
shades
or the gradients
okay
so i am going to use
my color map as cube helix
let me run it and show you the
pivot table
there you go
here you can see we have our pivot table
ready
now as i said in the beginning there are
a few
discrepancies in the data set so here
you can see
there's one called maharashtra and
there's also maharashtra triple star
this you can ignore even if i scroll
down you have madhya pradesh followed by
three asterisks you can ignore this
value as well even for bihar we have
so these have been duplicated
and
here you can see the different
state names and union territories then
on the top you have the confirmed cases
cured cases
the debts reported and the new
columns that we created
these are calculated columns recovery
rate and mortality rate
and we have ordered it in
descending order of confirmed cases so
so far
our data says that maharashtra has the
highest number of cases followed by
kerala karnataka tamil nadu andhra
pradesh and uttar prades so these are
the top
five states which have the highest
number of
confirmed cases
even if you see the mortality rate is
also high for maharashtra
and
if i scroll down
the mortality rate is also high for
uttarakhand if you see here
if i scroll further
your punjab the mortality rate is also
high
all right
so this was our first
visual that we created in the
kobe data analysis project
now moving ahead
we'll see the
top 10 states based on the number of
active cases
so we'll start
i'll give a comment top 10
active
cases
states
okay
so
we are going to explore another very
important pandas function in this which
is known as group by
so i'll first
pass in my data frame which is kovid
underscore df
dot followed by the group by function
i am going to group my data based on
state slash
union territory column
then i'll say
dot
max which is to find the
maximum value from the states
that have
the highest
active cases so i have passed in my
active cases column
and
we're also going to group it
based on the date column
after that
we're going to sort the values so i'll
use my function that is sort underscore
values
i'll say
short by
my column that is
active cases
let me bring this to the next line
underscore
cases
give a comma and say
ascending equal to
false
say dot
and then
reset my index
for that i'll use reset underscore index
function
okay
let's check if everything is fine
i have
missed a square bracket here let me give
another square bracket here okay
and all this we are going to store
in our
variable called top underscore 10
underscore active
underscore cases
okay
now let me go ahead and
run this cell
okay there is
a syntax error here
now let's run it okay
now i'll create another variable called
fig
here we'll pass in
the plt which is for matplotlib
library
and we'll give the
figure size
using the
fig size
argument
it's equal to and within a tuple and
passing the size let's say 16 comma 9
we'll run it
okay
and
let's give
a title to our plot so here we are going
to create a
bar plot
so
using plt.title we'll pass in the
title let's say top 10 states
with
most
active cases in india
i'll give a comma and pass in the size
of my title
let's say 25
okay you can see we are slowly
being able to
create our graph
the most important thing is to pass in
the
x-axis and the y-axis
i'll say ax which is for axis
to pass in the axis i am going to use
the bar plot function that is present
inside the c-bond library
i'll say sns.bar plot
i'll say data equal to
my
variable which is top underscore 10
underscore
states
this is actually active states
all right
and now
i'm going to use the
i lock
function
and
take the first 10 states so i'm using a
colon and then giving 10 as my value
iloc is for index location
i'll give a comma and say my
y-axis to be
active cases
give another comma and say my x-axis to
be
state
slash
union territory
give another comma
we are going to pass in the line
width
to 2
i'll say line width equal to 2
and will give
an edge color
let's say the edge color is
red
okay
so i have my
axis defined now
let's run it
there's an error here it says stopped in
active states not found
let's go to the top and see the exact
okay so this is
top 10 active cases let me change it to
cases here
now run it
okay the x axis also has a mistake this
should be
state slash union territory
now let me run it
there you go we have our
plot
created but as you can see here the
labels of the
different states and union territories
are overlapping so for that
let me first pass in the
x labels i'll say plt dot x
label
and my
x label would be states
then i'll say plt dot
by label
my y label will have the total
active cases
and finally i'll write plt dot show
before i run it let's collate all the
lines of code that we have written for
our
top 10 states for most active cases in
india into one cell
so what i'll do is i'll just copy this
and we'll keep
adding
in this cell itself
okay
i'll go to the top
next we'll copy
my figure size
and we'll
paste it here
next let's take the
title
and put it here
give us peace
and we are going to copy
the cell
and i'll paste it here
all right
now it's time to run it
there you go
you see it here
we have a nice
bar plot ready on the top you can see
the title top 10 states with most active
cases
and you see the edges are in red color
for all the bars
on the x-axis you have the different
state names maharashtra karnataka kerala
you also have andhra pradesh gujarat
west bengal and chatham
so as you can see
maharashtra
has the
highest number of active cases based on
our data followed by karnataka caroline
tamilnadu at second third and fourth
place respectively
and
in the ninth place we have west bengal
in the tenth place we have chattisgarh
on the y-axis you can see the total
active cases
which are
in lakhs
okay now moving ahead now we'll see the
top 10 states based on the total number
of
deaths
reported so i'll give a comment
top states
with
highest
debts
okay
so i'll first
create my variable
saying top 10 underscore
deaths
this will be very similar to
what we did here
just that we need to change a few
column names so instead of active cases
we'll be using depths
okay
so i'll start with my
data frame that is coveted underscore df
followed by using the
group by function and i want to group my
data
based on
the state slash
union territory column
then i'll choose the max function
and within
double square brackets i'll pass in
my column names
deaths and date
let's make it consistent i'll be using
single quotes
okay
i'll say dot
gonna
sort my
result therefore i'm using the sort
underscore values function
i want to sort it by
deaths column
i'll give another comma and say
ascending equal to false which means i
want to
order my result in
descending order
then i'll say dot reset underscore index
okay
after that i'll give my
figure size i'll say plt dot
figure and within brackets i'll pass in
my argument which is
fig size
equal to
using a tuple i'll say 18 comma let's
say 5
now let's give a title for that i'll use
the title function which is present in
the matplotlib library
i'll say
top 10 states with
most
deaths
and let's give a size to the title 25
now it's time for us to give the access
labels i'll just scroll down
okay
so i'll say ax equal to
again this will be a bar plot so i am
using my c bond library followed by the
bar plot function
my data will be top
underscore 10 underscore depths
which is this variable
i'll give
my index location iloc
i'm going to choose
12 states the reason being
there are some discrepancies in the data
i'll show you once i plot this result
so in the y-axis we'll have
deaths
column in the x axis we'll take
state
slash
union territory
okay i'll give another comma
and say
line width
equal to 2
and will give
an edge color to our
bars like we did here
so i'll say edge color
equal to let's say
black
okay
now
finally we'll give
the x label the y label
so i'll say plt dot x label
x label would be states
y label
will be
total
death cases
then i'll write plt dot show
now let's run it
there you go
you can see here we have a nice bar plot
on the top we have the title top 10
states with most deaths
now
what i specifically wanted you to
see was these discrepancies in the data
you can see here maharashtra is repeated
twice even
in our data that we collected from kegel
karnataka
spelling has an error you can see here
we have a few
rows of information where karnataka is
spelled as
k-e-r-a-a-n instead of k-a-r-n-a
all right so to
remove
these
two results or to ignore these two
results i had given
my index location till 12 so we have
maharashtra karnataka tamil nadu delhi
then uttar pradesh west bengal kerala
punjab andhra pradesh and chhattisgard
with the states that have the
most number of deaths reported
ok
now we'll create a line plot to see
the
growth or the trend of active cases for
top five states with most number of
confirmed cases so the states are
maharashtra karnataka kerala tamil nadu
and uttar pradesh i can show you
so these are the states with
highest number of active cases
okay
i'll just give a comment saying
growth
trend
all right
so for that
we'll start with our
figure size as
plt dot figure
i'll use my parameter fixed size equal
to
12 comma 6
i'll say
my axis as sns dot
this time we are going to create a line
plot
my data would be
the original data frame that is covered
underscore df
and
within square brackets i'll say coverage
underscore df
and we are going to pass in the
state or the union
territory column
i'll give
a dot and use the
is in function
so the
states should include
maharashtra
will give a comma the next state should
be
karnataka
next
we have
kerala
give another comma
my fourth state is tamil nadu
give a comma
and my fifth state would be
uttar pradesh
all right
so i'll give
a comma here and then say x equal to
the date column
y
will be
active cases column
and i'm going to use another parameter
called hue
which is to
give different colors to the different
states the five states that we are
looking for
so hue
will be my state slash
union territory column
okay
after this
i'll say
ax dot
set title
my title will be top 5
affected
states
in india
we'll give a size let's say
16
all right okay this should be size equal
to 16
and
to make sure everything is fine let me
just
move it to the above line
okay
now we'll run it
okay there is some error again
it says
invalid syntax let's see where we went
wrong
let me bring this to the above line
okay this should be covered underscore
df
okay
make sure you
keep these small errors in check
let's try and run it again
all right
if i scroll down
there you go here you can see we have
the top five affected states in india
you see the
different
states here and the colors so
this violet or the purple color is for
maharashtra you can see
how the
active cases
surged around
april and may
and then you can see
even for karnataka the active cases
surged very rapidly
around me
and june
then it has decreased luckily
similarly you can see the plots for even
uttar pradesh
as well as for tamil nadu so all the
five states you can see one common trend
that
after
march so around april
the cases started to emerge very rapidly
and
later after july they started dipping
okay
now
we are going to use our second data set
which is related to vaccination
all right
so first and foremost let me go ahead
and
print the data frame for you
so that you know
the data that we are going to use so
this is the data we are going to use
for our next
set of analysis
even this data has a few errors and you
can see there are a lot of missing
values it makes sense because not all
the days you would have
vaccination
for people
and
very crucial
error that we are going to deal with is
this
state column here you can see
in the state column we have india in a
few rows so we are going to ignore these
rows
all right
first let's rename
our updated on column to just
vaccine date
so
you can use the
rename function present in the pandas
library to do it so i'll say vaccine
underscore df dot
rename
i'll say columns equal to
within
curly braces
i'll write
updated
on
which is my
original column name
give a colon i want to change this to
vaccine underscore date
i'll give a comma
and say in place equal to true
so it will change
my
column name from updated on to vaccine
underscore date
in the
original data frame
let's run it
now
let me go ahead and print
the first
10 rows
in the data set
you can see here we have successfully
changed the column name to vaccine
underscore date the rest of the columns
remain the same
all right
now you can
check
the
total number of
columns
rows
the data types and the memory usage
using the
info function
here you can see it
we have total 24 columns
7845 entries
and these are the
columns that are present
and if i scroll further
you see here
sees
the memory usage and here on the right
you can see the
data type
cool
now as you saw
the data has a lot of missing values
let's find the sum of all the missing
values for each column
so i'll save action underscore df dot is
null
and then i'm going to use the sum
function over it
far on it there you go
so almost
all the columns have
missing values but columns such as
male individuals vaccinated female
individuals vaccinated even for columns
like the age groups there are a lot of
missing values
now in the next step we are going to
drop a few
missing value columns
so i'll say
a new variable called vaccination
i'll give the data frame name vaccine
underscore df and use the drop function
and inside the drop function we are
going to write
columns equal to
i'll pass in the
column names that i want to drop
i'll say
doses
administered
so this is the column that i want to
delete sputnik v doses administered
i'll give a comma
the second column is e e
f i
the next column is
18 to 44
years
within bracket
it has doses
administered
give a comma
i'll say 45 to
60
years
doses
administered
to another comma
the final column that we are going to
drop is
60 plus which is this one 60 plus years
deuces
administered
okay
so these are the columns that we want to
drop
and finally i'll give my parameter
access equal to 1
okay let me just recheck this
column names first one is sputnik v
doses administer then we have
efi
followed by 18 to 44 years doses
administered then we have 45 to 60 years
doses administered
finally we have 60 plus years
i've added
a s here which was missing and there
should be a space as well
because there's a space here in the
column now let's run it
all right
so we have successfully dropped
the columns that we wanted to drop
now i'll say vaccination dot head
you can see here
we have dropped those columns and we are
left with these columns now
okay now
we are going to
create a
plot
that is a pi plot to see
the vaccination for male and
female individuals so i'll give a
comment
as male versus
female vaccination
to create this pie plot i am going to
use the plotly library that we had
imported which is this one plotly
okay
so first of all we need to filter out
the
male individuals
from our data frame
i'll say male equal to
vaccination
meal
and passing in the column
individuals
we need to recheck the variable name
whether it is correct or not
you see here male
individuals vaccinated
then i'll say
dot
sum
similarly we'll filter out the female
individuals
i'll say female equal to
vaccination
which is my new data frame
within square brackets i'll pass in the
column name female
individual
vaccinated
i'll say dot sum
okay
okay these should be individuals as per
the
column name present in the data frame
cool
now i'm going to say px
dot pi function which is present in the
plotly library
i am going to
give the names of the
pies
so first one is meal
and the second one is
female
give a comma and say
values
equal to
male comma
female
then i'll give a comma and pass in my
title which
is male and
female vaccination
okay
this should be names
all right now let's go ahead and run
this cell
it will take some time to create the
pie chart here we go
see here i have my title male and female
vaccination
so these are the two
pies or the areas
you have the label female and the value
here you have the label meal and the
value
so from our data you can see 53 percent
male
individuals have been vaccinated
compared to 47 percent for females
okay
now we are going to drop all those rows
where
our state was mentioned as india in the
original data set
i had shown this to you in the beginning
so we are going to remove
rows
where
state is india
okay
so to do that i'll say
vaccine i'm creating another variable
called vaccine
and
we'll use our original data frame that
we had imported
which is vaccine underscore df
i'll say
vaccine underscore
df
dot
state
not equal to
india
now let's
print vaccine
okay you can see here we have our
data frame printed and from this data
frame we are taking only those values
or the rows where state is not equal to
india
cool
now what we are going to do is
will rename the last column which is
total individuals vaccinated to
just total
so i'll say vaccine dot
rename
we'll use the parameter columns equal to
within
curly braces i'll say
total
individuals
vaccinated
give a colon and we'll change this to
just total
give a comma and say in place equal to
true
and finally i'll print my
head of the new data frame
this should be columns equal to
okay
now you can see here if i scroll to the
right and if i check
we have successfully renamed our column
all right
now moving on to the last two
visualizations that we'll see in this
first project using python that is to
find the states with most number of
vaccinated individuals and the state
with the least number of vaccinated
individuals
okay
just give a comment
most
vaccinated
state
okay for this i'll first create a
variable called wax underscore
vac which is for maximum vaccination
i'm going to use my
data frame vaccine
followed by the group by function
i want to grip it by state column
and
we'll find the total sum
of vaccinated individuals
for each state
i'll convert this to frame
there should be a dot
to underscore frame
and i'll pass in my column name which is
total
after that
i'll say max underscore vac
equal to
max underscore vac dot
short
underscore values
i'm going to sort it by
my total column
and say ascending equal to false which
means i want to sort it in descending
order
so that we have the
states with the
highest number of
individuals vaccinated
i want the top five states
now
let's go ahead and
print it
so this will create a nice table for us
there you go
here you can see
we have maharashtra uttar pradesh
rajasthan gujarat in west bengal as the
top five states with most number of
vaccinated individuals
now we are going to use this table and
convert it into a
chart
now i had already written my
code for the
bar plot i am just going to paste it
so here i have defined my
figure size as 10 comma 5
then i am giving a title as top five
accented states in india and the size is
20
after that i have created a variable
called x
which is going to store my bar plot
this bar plot we have created using the
c bond library
and
you see here i have my
y axis defined
then
i have the line width and the edge color
as well
i have given my x label as states by
label as vaccination and i'm finally
going to display my plot so let's go
ahead and run it
okay you can see it here
we have converted this table into a bar
plot now
so first we have maharashtra with the
highest
number of vaccinations
then we have uttar pradesh rajasthan
gujarat and west bengal now
i want
the viewers
watching this video to
find the states with least number of
vaccinated individuals and convert that
table into a
bar plot that will show the
bottom five vaccinated states in india
which means the states which have
least number of individuals vaccinated
so please go ahead and put your
codes in the comments section of the
video it will be very similar to these
two cells just that now we want to know
the least five vaccinated states in
india
so please put the code snippets in the
comments section of this video we'll be
more than happy to know from you in case
you are not able to do it we'll
definitely keep the answers in the
comments itself
all right
so this brings us to the end of the
first project on kovit data analysis
using python
so
in this project we used two data sets
one was on
the coveted 19
india data set for different states and
union territories and the second data
set that we used was for
analyzing the status of vaccination in
the different states in india
now we'll move on to our second project
okay so before moving on to our tableau
project let's see the final quiz
which of the following is not a common
coronavirus symptom so this question is
to make you aware of the correct coveted
symptoms
here are the options
is it a fever
b
vision loss c loss of taste and smell or
is it d curve please put your answers in
the comments section of the video and
let us know what you think
now we'll move on to our second govet
data analysis project for this project
we'll be using the tableau software and
a global coronavirus data set
first we look at the data set and the
fields we have
okay so i am in my data set folder
we have already seen the first two data
sets in our
python project
this time we are going to use the global
covet data let me open it
all right so here you can see
we have the different country names
there are
192 countries in our data set
let me go to the top
so
we have
country or region
we also have the code
for each of the countries
then we have column called last updated
so here you can see our data is still
12th of march 2021
and there are two columns which
don't have any information that is
people hospitalized and people
tested
then we have a column called
active cases then we have a column for
confirmed cases
in the different
countries we have the number of debts
and then we have the incident rate
the latitude and the longitude for the
countries
then we have the mortality rate
this is in fractions
then we have the number of
recovered cases and finally we have a
column called uid so we'll be mostly
using the country column
active
confirmed deaths
and the recovered cases column
and we'll be using the tableau software
to create interesting visualizations and
we'll convert those visuals and put it
in the form of a dashboard
towards the end of the project
okay so let me
close this file or let it be open
i'll search for tableau public you can
see here i have
tableau public installed
you can use the
desktop version of tableau or the public
version of tableau
so for this project we are going to use
the
tableau public edition
so here you can see i have
created a few visuals already
if you want you can clear them out
okay now
the first thing we need to do is to
connect our csv data set to tableau for
that
under connect
we have to a file
i'm going to use
text file
and under
chrome downloads i'll search for my
folder
kovid
dash india
and here i have my
global covet data file let me open it
this will take some time to load
there you can see
so on the tableau you can see the view
here
it shows the country or the region
you have the last update
you have columns like active confirmed
deaths
mortality rate and recovered
and here you can see the
symbols for the
different columns so this is
a globe which means this field
is a
region or a
geographic field
abc means it's a text field then we have
the calendar which is for a date field
abc our
text field and this
hash represents
numeric fields
all right
so now that we have loaded our data
let me just click on sheet1
so this is the canvas where we are going
to
create our different
reports
all right
so on the left you can see there are two
panes the data pane and the analytics
pane
in the data pane you can see the
name of the data set global covet data
and here you can see the
different
columns that we have in the data set so
on the top
the ones marked in
blue are called as dimensions
and at the bottom whatever you see
are marked in green and are called as
measures
so dimensions are always represented
with blue icons and measures are in
green icons
so
tableau has automatically detected the
different
data types for each of the
columns
all right
so
first of all we are going to create a
simple table
to see the total number of confirmed
cases for each of the
countries
so for that i'm going to drag my country
or the region column on to rows here you
have rows i'll just drag it and drop it
here
there you go it has populated all my
country names starting from afghanistan
till
jimbaway so it has ordered in
ascending order of alphabets
now
to see the total confirmed cases for
each country i am going to drag my
confirmed
column onto text
so here under marks card you have
the text option i'll just drag it and
drop it here
there you go
so tableau how easily has
shown me a table where you can see the
different country names and on the right
you have the total number of cases that
have emerged
from these countries
now this is not the most recent data as
i told you this data was till march 2021
cool now you can go ahead and
short the
table based on the
total confirmed cases here on the top
you can see here
there are two options to sort in
ascending order or in descending order
let's first sort in
ascending order
by sum of confirmed cases with
few cases
and if i scroll down
you have france uk russia brazil india
and u.s with the highest number of
kovite 19 cases
if you want you can also
short it in
descending order so that the countries
with the highest number of confirmed
cases appear at the top
you can see it here
and these are the countries that have
very few covet cases
now you can convert this
simple table into different charts and
graphs
to do that
here on the
right top corner you have an option
called show me
now
i can just click on
this horizontal bar graph
so that will automatically convert my
table into a bar graph
again you can go ahead and
short the data
there you go
so here you have u.s india brazil russia
uk france spain and italy this is a
horizontal bar graph
sorted in
descending order of confirmed cases
now suppose you want to display only the
top few countries with the highest
number of confirmed cases for that you
can select these bars
so i'll select till let's say
germany
or let's say till argentina
okay and i'll click on keep only you can
see it here it says 12 items selected
that is the sum of confirmed cases i'll
just click on keep only
there you go
so
this horizontal bar graph has
information only for these
few countries that have the highest
number of confirmed cases
now you can go ahead and
play with the color formatting
so here under colors let me choose
a green color
okay
now you can mark here since we selected
only the top 12 countries with the
highest number of confirmed cases so
what we did was we just filtered it to
the top 12 countries so tableau has
automatically added country region in
the
filters card
now if you want you can go ahead and
edit this filter as well
suppose you want to remove argentina you
can just uncheck this click on apply and
ok you see here argentina has been
removed i'll click on
undo so ctrl z to get it back cool
now you can convert this
horizontal bar plot into a vertical bar
plot let me show you how to do it i'll
just remove these
fields from my
chart
now what i'm going to do is i'll
drag country or region onto columns
and i'll have
confirmed
column under rows
there you go here you can see we have
a vertical bar plot now
and again you can use the access now to
short your data this is in
descending order similarly you can sort
it in ascending order here you have the
option to
sort your data
okay
cool
and below you can see the
different country names
all right
now you can go ahead and
give
a name to this sheet let's say
top 10
confirmed
countries
to supply
and click on ok you have the title to
this plot
similarly you can change it here as well
top 10
confirmed
countries
okay
now let's move on to our second
visualization where we will create a
global map so this global map will show
the different countries
present
in the map and the cases that they have
so to create the map first i'll drag my
longitude
generated
field onto columns and then i'll drag
latitude on to rows
you see here we have the map ready
and now
i'll drag
country region onto detail
so this will give you
the different country names you can see
here we have canada
the united states
mexico
here you have india
sri lanka
there's australia
this is brazil
and similarly we have spain france
belgium
there's
italy here we have also greece
similarly we have the african countries
like
central african republic this congo
angola
and on the top you have russia and this
is iceland so on and so forth
now
i am going to drag
the
active cases column onto
detail again
now if i hover the cursor you can see
the
active numbers for brazil you can see
for india
you have
countries like china
then here you have thailand
algeria now
i'm going to
drag the confirmed cases column on to
label
so that you have the labels here you can
see here the confirmed labels
cool
now if you only want to focus on a few
countries
present in a particular region you can
highlight that region for example
suppose
for europe you want to focus on this
region if you select it it will
highlight only those countries and if
you hover your mouse over these points
it will show you the active cases and
the total number of confirmed cases
all right now if you want you can go
ahead and change the color of the
circles let's see i'll keep it as
red
okay
so this is how you can create a
map to represent the different active
and
confirmed cases
i'll rename the title to
global
cases
i'll just click on apply and ok
similarly i'll change the sheet name as
well to
global cases
okay
now from this map you can see the
countries such as usa
brazil
you have russia
and india with the
highest number of kovit 19 cases even in
countries such as
spain the numbers are
really high
and
a lot of the african countries were also
impacted
and these small countries like solomon
islands you have
fizzy islands with few number of cases
even for new zealand as well
all right
now moving to our next
visual
now we are going to see the top 10
countries where highest debts have been
reported so far due to the pandemic for
this we will create a tree map now
so first of all i'll
choose my country column and
put it under
columns
and then i'll select
the depths column and put it under rows
i have the
bar plot ready
next i'll go to show me and here i have
the option to select a tree map
you see here for a tree map you need one
or more dimensions and one or two
measures so i'll just click on this tree
map
okay here you can see i have my tree map
ready so tableau has automatically
adjusted my fields so it has removed my
fields from rows and columns and put it
under
size color and
label
next i will drag my
country column and put it under filters
and from here
i am going to choose top
i'll filter by field i'm going to select
the top 10
countries
based on the total number of
deaths just click on apply and click on
ok
so
these are the countries us brazil mexico
india united kingdom italy russia spain
france germany
which have the highest number of deaths
reported
now
you can also
give the label
i'll
put the deaths column under label so
that you have the labels here
all right so this was a tree map that we
created to show the
top 10 countries with the highest
number of deaths
i'll just
change the title top 10
deaths
cases
now you can also edit the title in terms
of the font color and everything
that's i'll keep it tableau bold
and i'll choose this as 14 click on
apply and okay
there you go
similarly let's
rename the sheet to
death cases
cool
now moving
to the next visualization where we'll
see
about the recoveries
so before we move on to
create a visualization for the
top 10 or let's say the bottom 10
countries in terms of recoveries let me
show you how to change the color of the
stream app
so here
by default tableau select the automatic
palette
if you want you can change it to
different
palettes let's say i'll go with
gold purple diverging
click on apply and i'll click on ok
if this is
not looking
that great you can select another one
let's
see red green white diverging
cool
now let's
go to our
fourth visualization which is about
top 10
recoveries
i'll click on apply and ok
first i'll drag my country or the region
column
under
columns
and then i will take
the recovered column under rows
this time
instead of
sum
we are going to choose
average
okay
and here
i'll select
my
packed bubble chart
after that i am going to drag my country
or region onto colors
and then i'll also
put country under
filters so i'll go to
the top
menu
and i'll filter it by field
i want to show the top 10 countries
based on the average number of
recoveries
if you click on apply and okay
you can see here
these are the countries that have
the highest number of
average recoveries you have india brazil
turkey italy argentina germany colombia
russia poland and mexico
i'll just rename this sheet to
recovery cases
cool
now let's move on to our next visual
okay so here we are going to create a
scatter plot to analyze the total
confirmed cases versus the total number
of deaths so whenever you have two
numeric fields it is better to create a
scatter plot to visualize the
cases
so for that i'm going to
drag my confirmed
cases to columns and then i'll drag
my
deaths column onto rows
okay
so by default
the shape is a circle
and
to see all the countries i am going to
drag country under color
i'll say add all members
there you go
here
you can see the legend
for the different
countries
and
the top you have
us with the highest number of confirmed
cases and the highest number of
deaths as per our data set
then you also have brazil here which has
the second highest number of deaths
then you have
mexico
followed by india
so this data is not a very recent data
this data was last updated on
march
now from this we are going to filter out
the top 10 countries with the highest
number of
confirmed cases
and the deaths
so for that i will drag my country
column onto filters
and i'll go to top
filter by field
i'll say top 10
and i'll click on
apply and ok
so here you can see we have siberia
sweden
belgium
netherlands
spain
italy france russia
uk and
you have brazil
so these are the countries which have
the
highest number of
active cases
so instead of active let's select deaths
click on apply and okay
okay
now if you see we have us here brazil
india
then mexico
uk
russia france
italy germany and spain which have the
highest number of
deaths reported so far
now if you want you can
change
the
size of the circles based on the
highest number of active cases so i can
just drag my active column under size
so you can see here
spain france
uk have the highest number of active
cases
now let's say instead of active i'll
just have
my confirmed cases under size okay
and then
you can also change the shape from
circle to
any other shape let's say square or
this asterix
okay
let's go with the triangle
cool
i'll rename this sheet to
confirmed versus
depths
click on apply and okay
i'll rename this to
confirmed
versus
deaths
all right
now moving on to our
next visualization where we will see
the mortality
for each of the countries
and figure out which countries have the
highest
mortality rate
okay
so
first i'll drag
mortality rate
onto
column
and then i'll have
my
country column under rows
so there you go
now let me go ahead and
sort it in
descending order
so you can see here you have yemen
there is mexico syria sudan egypt
equator china and other countries which
have the highest mortality
rate and you can also
select the country region under colors
let's go ahead and edit the
color
instead of automatic let's select summer
or
you can go for some other palette let's
say
tableau
classic medium i'll assign this palette
yes i'll apply and okay
all right
finally
we'll
move ahead to our
last visualization where we'll create a
dual access chart
so the dual axis chart in tableau will
have one column and two different
visualizations on the rows so here you
have
one
column and on the right also you will
have one column with their own access
values
so this dual axis chart will be for
recovered cases and the
death cases let me show you how to do it
so i'll drag
my country
field onto
columns
and then
i'll choose
recovered column onto
rows
so here i have got my
line chart
and the second
column i'm going to choose is the depths
column
i'll hold my
cursor and i'll place it
when i get this
green color rectangle i'll place it here
there you go so now we have created two
measure names deaths and
recovered
and here you have the access values
you can synchronize the access values if
you want
the recovered cases are in millions and
the deaths are in thousands
now let's go ahead and
change
the
recovered line to
bars
and
we're going to short it
okay
now let's change the color
we'll select let's say
blue
i'll assign the palette click on apply
and ok
and if you want you can also change the
color
for
depths
from blue to let's say
winter i'll assign the palette click on
apply and okay
you can have whichever color you want
and to make the access seam you can just
right click on this axis and click on
synchronize
access so here you can see the values
let's keep it in thousands only
cool
i'll rename this sheet to
dual access
okay
now before we move ahead and create our
final dashboard i want to show you
one more
feature in tableau that is to format the
labels so you can see here instead of
writing 5 lakh 30 821 we can change this
in terms of millions or thousands and
write it as let's say 530 k
to do that
what i'll do is i'll go to format and
here we have the option
to select
font
and in font i'll go to fields and
click on sum of
deaths and here
in this pane
i'll choose
number custom
decimal places will be 0
and
display units i'll select
thousands
you can see here the values have been
changed to 531k 193k 158k
so on and so forth
cool
now let's go ahead and create our final
dashboard here is the option to create a
new dashboard so i'll just click on
new dashboard
and we are going to increase the
size here so that
it fits our
view
so we have selected the default view and
the size i am going to
choose here is automatic so now we can
drop our sheets one by one
first let's drag the global cases
sheet here
okay you can see we have our map
now
i'm going to choose the top 10 confirmed
cases
right
and after that
we'll choose the
death cases sheet so tableau will prompt
you to place the sheet
at the right location
okay
and now
i'll choose my
fifth visual which is confirmed versus
deaths
and if you want you can choose any one
of
these let's say i'll take the dual axis
chart
now you can just
minimize the
sheets and adjust the
sizes
to
make it look better
okay
so you can see here we have our
dashboard ready now you can still
go ahead and customize the dashboards in
terms of adding different
filters to it we are not going to
show that now you are getting some
messages here two are known for nulls
you
can
remove them as well and here on the top
you have the option to
click on the presentation mode
the hugo so this is our final dashboard
that we have created all right so this
brings us to the end of the
second
coronavirus data analysis project using
tableau
now you can just click on escape to go
back all right now you can save this
and
this will be published in the
tableau public
platform under your profile
so that brings us to the end of this
video tutorial on kobe data analysis
project using python and tableau welcome
to this exciting video on olympics data
set analysis using python by simply loan
this is going to be a very interesting
and interactive session where i'll give
you a brief about the history of
olympics and throw some light into the
recently held tokyo olympics
but we'll focus more on using olympics
dataset that is available on kegel and
perform some exploratory data analysis
you will understand how to use different
functions in python to analyze and
extract meaningful information
during the course of our discussion i'll
be asking you a few general questions
related to the olympics try to answer
them in the comments section of the
video so let's begin
the olympics is one of the biggest
sporting events on the planet
it is held every four years
the first modern olympics took place in
athens greece in 1896
as per national geographic the original
olympics took place in 776 bc
so they began as part of an ancient
greek festival with celebrated jews the
greek god of sky and weather
the rings in the olympics logo represent
the five continents europe africa asia
the americas and oceania
from 1924 to 1992 the winter and the
summer olympics took place in the same
year but now they alternate every two
years
before i move on here is an interesting
question for you
only two people have ever won gold
medals at both the summer and the winter
olympics
who are those two people
please share your answers in the
comments section of the video we would
like to know from you
the summer olympics in tokyo began on
the 23rd of july and recently concluded
on the 8th of august
we got to witness some thriller matches
that went down to the wire some amazing
victories and sadly there were a lot of
heartbreaks as well
winning and losing are part and parcel
of any game
fans across the world were really happy
to see this global event happen this
year following last year's postponement
due to the coronavirus pandemic
with our olympic fever high let's take
this opportunity to work around a
project to perform exploratory data
analysis using python to analyze and
visualize past olympics data and answer
specific questions in this video we will
be using specific python libraries such
as numpy pandas matplotlib and cbond to
make sense of our data and extract
meaningful information
we are going to visualize our results
with different charts and graphs
before i show you the data set that we
are going to use for our analysis
i have another general question for you
which is the first olympics where all
the participating countries sent female
athletes a repeat which is the first
olympics where all the participating
countries sent female athletes
put the year and the city name where the
olympics was held in the comments
section of the video
we'll be more than happy to hear from
you
now
let me go ahead and show you the data
sets that we'll be using in this video
so here you can see i have my
olympics data set folder that has two
datasets these are csv files one is
called the athlete underscore events and
the other one is called noc underscore
regions
so
we'll be using these two data sets these
data sets can be downloaded from kegel
we will post the data set links in the
description of the video please go ahead
and download them these data sets have
been directly taken from the internet
now i'll show you the data sets
so this is my first data set you can see
on the top athlete underscore events so
i have
around 15 columns you can see the count
here and there are nearly
2 lakh 71 116 rows of information
so this is a huge data set that we are
going to use
the other data set we are going
to use in this demo is called noc
underscore regions now here one thing to
note is
noc stands for national olympic
committee this is a three letter code
that is given by the olympic committee
we have the region name so afg is for
afghanistan
you have alb for albania elg for algeria
we have also a column called nodes you
find some
notes about the
region for example here antiqua is
actually antiqua and barbuda
all right
let's move to the
first data set that i showed you
this is our primary data set for our
demo
so these data sets have been directly
taken from the internet and were not
validated so the results that you will
see in the demo is purely based on the
data that we have collected
so the file athlete underscore
events.csv contains
nearly 2 lakhs 71 116 rows of
information and there are 15 columns
so each row corresponds to an individual
athlete competing in an individual
olympic event
so here id is actually a unique number
for each athlete then we have the name
which is basically the athlete's name we
have the sex or the gender which is male
or f for female
then we have the age of the athlete
which is in terms of integers
we have the height in centimeters of the
athletes then we have the weight in
kilograms
we have the team name these are the
country names you have china denmark
netherland there are around 200 country
names
then we have the noc as i said noc
is a three-letter code that stands for
national
olympic committee
we have the games this games contains
the year and the season you can see here
1992 summer you also have the winter
olympic information
all right
then we have a specific year column
to
tell you in which year this event had
occurred
now the year column is also an integer
column
we have the season so whether it was
summer olympics or winter olympics
then we have the city name this is the
host city
then we have the sport name you can see
here we have basketball judo football
tug of war
speed skating
there are so many
then we have another column called event
which is the complete even name as you
can see the sport name is basketball but
the even name is basketball men's
basketball to be very specific
again for speed skating you have
different categories like women's
thousand meters 500 meters
all right
now the final column is the middle
column so it has
the information about the athlete
whether
the athlete had won a medal bait gold
silver branch and n a means that athlete
did not win any medals so we'll use
these two data sets
now let's
get started with the demo
we'll be using jupyter notebook for our
analysis so i'll take you to my jupyter
notebook right away
i've opened it on chrome so this is my
jupyter notebook that we are going to
use you can see here olympics data set
analysis
i have already
have a few cells that have been filled
with some piece of code and you can see
there are
some comments written as well we are
going to use this data set
so let's get started
first and foremost we'll import the data
sets so we are going to use
numpy pandas matplotlib and cbon
let me hit shift enter to
import all the
libraries
all right
now the next thing is to load the
datasets
using
pandas read underscore csv function
so
i'll create a variable called athletes
i'll say equal to
pd dot i'll use the read underscore csv
function
and inside this function will give the
location
of the files so i'll copy this location
and here i'll paste
make sure this is within
quotations
and these are all
forward slash
give another forward slash
and after that i'll give the
file name that is
athlete
underscore
evens
dot csv
i'll close the quotation
let's run it
okay
similarly we will
load the second data set i'll create
another variable called regions
so it will have my data frame i'll use
the same function pd dot read underscore
csv
i'll just copy this
file path
till here
we paste it
and
i'll give my second file name which is
noc underscore
regions dot csv
you can verify here
the first one is athlete underscore
events the second one is noc underscore
regions
okay i'll close the quotation and we'll
run it again
okay there seems to be some error i
think this is the
regions cool
now moving ahead
let's see the
first few rows of both the data sets
i'll use the head function for that
i'll say
athletes dot head
so this will print the first five rows
from my data set
athletes you can see here
from 0 to 4 you have five rows of
information the id name sex or the
gender
each height weight
if i go to the right you have games
year season sport event and medal
now let's see the
second data set that we
imported or loaded
i'll say regions dot head
it says regions
is not defined
let me cross check it
okay i have taken it as region let's
make it regions
cool
now let's run it there you go so these
are the first five rows from our second
data set you have noc region and some
nodes
all right
now the next step is to combine
both the data sets so we'll join the
data frames using the pandas merge
function
let me show you how to do it
so this is going to be a horizontal join
i'll create a variable
called athletes underscore df
then
i'll use my first
variable which is athletes
i'll say dot merge which is my function
name i'm going to merge
the regions data frame
i'll use the how parameter
in how i'll give my value as
i want to do a left join
and my common column in both the data
sets is actually noc
so i'm going to use
the noc column as my common column to
merge both the data sets
now let's go ahead
and print the
most data frame i'll say athletes
underscore df.head
let's run it
there you go
so
if you see clearly if i move to the
right you can see here we have added two
more columns that were present in the
second data set which was regions so we
have regions and nodes
added to my
first data set that is
athletes underscore
events
cool
now one thing to note here is
see the column names are not consistent
if you see here the rest of the columns
start with a capital letter but if you
see the last two columns that we just
added now start with a lowercase letter
so we'll use
the rename function to
make the column names consistent
but before that let's
see the
shape of the data frame so i'll print
the shape of the data frame to know the
total number of rows and columns
i'll say
athletes if i hit tab
you will see it will give me
the prompt i will select athletes
underscore df
i'll use the
shape attribute
let's run it
and see the result you can see here it
gives me the total number of rows so 2
lakh 71 116 rows and earlier we had 15
columns in the first data set and now
that we have added two more columns so
the total number of columns becomes
17 now
cool
so now it's time to make the
column names consistent
so i'll show you how to do it i'll say
athletes underscore df
dot i'll use the rename function
and then
i'll say
columns
equal to
i'll use curly braces
my first column
that is region i want to change it to
a region but the r should be capital now
or upper case
i'll give a comma
and then say
my second column
this should be
a region actually
my second column that is notes
i want to
change the first letter to uppercase so
i'll say capital n
the rest all remains same
i'll give a comma here and say
in place equal to true
so it will change
the column names and will reflect
in this athletes underscore df data
frame
let's run it now to verify you can again
use the head function i'll run this
again
let me scroll down and move to the right
you can see the difference there you go
so we have successfully renamed the last
two columns region and nodes
alright
now moving ahead
now
i'll show you how you can use the info
method to print information about a data
frame including the index data type the
column data types
normal values and memory usage
so for that you just need to use the
info function so i'll write
athletes underscore df
dot info
let's run it there you go so here we
have the
data columns you can see total
17 columns you have two lags seventy one
thousand hundred and sixteen rows or
entries then you have the
different column names and
you say it says no null and the data
type of the column
below you can see some information about
the memory usage
all right
next
the describe method is used for
calculating statistical information such
as mean standard deviation the
percentiles of the numerical values of
the data frame and much more
it analyzes both numeric and object
series and also the data frame column
sets of mixed data types
so let me show you how using
the describe function you can
display
some statistical
summary
i'll just write
describe
and
give parenthesis let's run it
okay if i scroll down
you can see here
by default
the describe function will only give
information about numerical columns
so here you can see we have the total
count the mean of each of these columns
you have the standard deviation
the minimum and maximum value and then
we have the 25th percentile the 50th
percentile and the 75th percentile value
of
the columns id age height weight and
year
all right
now one thing to notice here is if you
see the year column
the minimum year is 1896
so this is when
olympics started
and until recently
the rio olympics that was held in 2016.
all right
now moving ahead
now let's check if there are any null
values present in the columns of the
data set
so first i am going to create
a variable called
nan values
give equal to
i'll see
athletes underscore df
and the function to check is i'll say is
an a
i'll create another
variable
called nan underscore
columns
and here i'll use the any function i'll
say nan underscore this
variable which is underscore values
dot i'll see any
and i'll print
my nan columns variable
so this will display the result in terms
of
boolean values so if there are any null
or nan or missing values in any of the
columns it will say true otherwise it
will say false
let's display the result
there you go
so if you mark here clearly
so there are
nearly six columns where we have missing
values you have
age height wheat metal region and notes
columns that have
missing values so hence
it has given us true the rest of the
columns do not have any nan or missing
values hence they are false
all right
let me scroll down
now
let's see the total number of null
values for the
above
six columns
so i'll say
athletes
underscore df
dot
i'll use the function is null
and again i'll use this sum function
okay this should be is null
if i run it
you can see it here
so our age column has 9474
rows where we have null values
then we have
some null values for the height column
as well for the weight column so these
are the total number of
rows where we don't have
any information regarding each height
wheat or region
notes this medal is
self-explanatory because a lot of the
athletes who participate in olympics
don't win any medals so for them
the value is any
now before i move ahead
i have a question for
you people so the question is i want you
to print the column names containing
null values or missing values in the
form of a list
so
please answer this question and put it
in the comments section of the video we
would be happy to
know your approach
so the question i'll repeat it again i
want you people to print the column
names containing null values or missing
values in the form of a list
so basically
on the top we saw there were
six columns that had
null values i want you to print these
six
columns in the form of a list
all right now moving ahead
now let's see the data for specific
countries
let's say you want to see the athletes
who have participated in the olympic
games from the beginning for india
for that you can filter your result
using a function called query
so let me show you how to do it i'll say
athletes underscore df
dot
will use the query function
and then
i'll say
team
which is my column name
should be equal to equal to and the
value i'll give is india
now let's
display the first five
rows of information
or the details for the athletes who are
from india if i run this
okay there is some error here
okay so we need to make sure this entire
expression or the condition should be
within
single quote i'll just
delete this single quote from here and
we'll add it in the end
now let's
run it the yuko
so here you can see we have
the top five rows
of
the athletes who are from india you can
see here the region is india you can see
the noc's india the team is india
and
let me go to the left you can see the
name of the athlete
the sex each
so for each you have some missing values
you have to wait
team year and everything
all right
similarly you can also check for
japan let me just copy the
above code
i'll paste it here
and instead of india i'll say
japan i'll run it
there you go
so if you see here
you can see all the details are for the
athletes who are from japan
all right
now moving ahead
now i want to know the top 10 countries
who have participated since the
inception of olympics in
1896.
so for that i'll create a variable
called top underscore 10 underscore
countries
let's say equal to
i'll use my data frame that is
athletes underscore
df
i'll say dot
team
then i'll use the function
value underscore
counts
i'm going to
sort
my count
in ascending order
just mark the way in which i am writing
the functions
any error in terms of syntax or the flow
will
throw you an error
i want to display the top 10 countries
now let's go ahead and
print it i'll say
top underscore 10 underscore countries
all right
let me run it
okay it has given us an error let's
debug it okay so this should be
value
counts and not count
let's run it again
another error
okay
so this should be
short underscore values and not value
let's run it again
there you go
so here you can see the top 10 countries
participating in olympics since
1896 you have united states then we have
france so these are the number of
participants who have taken part
since 1896.
so the most number of participants have
come from us then we have france great
britain italy germany canada japan
sweden
we also have australia and hungary
i'll scroll down
now we are going to convert this table
that we got or the output that we got
in the form of a graph
so i am trying to create a bar plot to
plot the
top 10 countries who have participated
in olympics so here i am using the
figure function to give the figure size
so these are the dimensions 12 comma 6.
now i'll tell you what this plt x6 means
just wait for a while
i have given a title to my plot saying
overall participation by country
and then
using the c-bond library and the bar
plot function
i am plotting the
x
and the
y-axis so my x-axis has top
i should make this top 10 countries
because above we used top underscore 10
underscore countries similarly for
y axis i'll make it top underscore 10
underscore countries and then i'm using
a color palette called set 2
let's run it
there you go so if i scroll down you can
see here we have a nice
bar plot
this is a vertical bar plot
and here you can see the bars which
represent the different country names
first we have united states which has
the highest participation since the
beginning of the olympics then we have
france great britain italy germany
canada
and we have the rest of the countries
cool
now moving ahead
the next visualization we are going to
see is the age distribution of the
athletes
so for this we are going to create a
histogram
i'll be using the matplotlib library
specifically for this visualization
so i'll say plt dot figure
we'll give the figure size using the
argument fig size
equal to
and this will be a tuple actually
my size is going to be 12 comma 6
i'll say
plt
dot
title
now you can give
any title that you want i'll say
each
distribution
of the
athletes
then we'll also give the x labels i'll
say plt dot
x label
this will have age
then we see plt dot y label
and this will have
the label as number of
participants
next
i'm going to use the hist function so
i'll say plt.test
and i'll
pass in my data frame that is
athletes
underscore df
dot
age
which is my column name
comma
i am going to pass in the
bins
for that i am going to use the np dot
earnings function so mp is for numpy
and inside this i'll say
10 comma
80 comma
2
so my bins will start from the value 10
and go until 80 with a size of 2
comma
i'll give another parameter that is
going to specify the color of the bins i
want my color to be
orange
and then
i'll use
the edge color to separate the bins
lch color this is the
parameter or the argument name and the
color i want is white
let's give a
semicolon here
and this should be edge color there's a
spelling mistake here
now let's run it and we'll see the
output
so there you go
so this is a nice histogram that shows
the distribution of the
age of the athletes you can see the
title each distribution of the athletes
on the y-axis you have the number of
participants on the x axis we have the
age values ranging from
10 to 80 with a size of
2
and if you see this
we have
most number of athletes
who have each between
20 to 30 you can see here
so early 20s we have maximum number of
athletes participating in the olympics
we also have a few athletes who are
beyond 40 years of age you can see here
we have a
few athletes
even closer to 60 also
and similarly we have a few athletes who
are under 18 years of age
all right
now you can see here the bins we had
taken orange color so our all the
bars are represented in orange color
and the edge you can see here we have
the white color
alright
now moving ahead
now in the initial slides of the video
we discussed the summer and winter
olympic games let's look at the
different sporting events that are part
of the summer and winter olympic games
just to give you a heads up the winter
olympic games are held once every four
years for sports practiced on snow and
ice
so here i have my variable name winter
underscore sports so i'm extracting
for season equal to equal to
winter and i am going to display only
the unique values now let me run this
cell
okay so you can see here these are the
different windows ports that are
held
during the winter olympics now similarly
let's see for
summer olympics so what i'm going to do
here is i'll just copy this
cell of code and we'll edit the
variables i'll say summer underscore
sports
athletes underscore df remains the same
here season will change it to
summer
dot sport dot unique remains the same
and
here i'll say summer underscore sports
that should be small
now let's run it
there you go
so here you can see we have
more number of olympic sports that are
held during the summer olympics compared
to
winter olympics
so these are the sports that are played
on snow and ice
and these are the sports that are played
during
summer
moving ahead
now it's time to analyze the total
number of male and female participants
who have taken part in different games
since 1896 till 2016 rio olympics
all right
so i'll say
gender
underscore counts which is my variable
name
i'll use my
data frame that is
athletes underscore df
dot
my variable name that is sex
dot
value underscore
counts
and then we are going to print
gender underscore counts
let's run this
there you go
so since the inception of olympics
we have more number of male participants
than
female participants
now here in this current cell you
can see we are trying to plot a
pie chart for male and female athletes
so i have given my figure size then i
have my title as gender distribution i
am using the matplotlib library and the
pi function
i am using the variable gender counts
that we used here
then i'm giving my labels as gender
underscore counts dot index now i'm
using this auto pct the auto pct
parameter enables you to display the
percent
value using python string formatting so
this is my string formatting that i have
used and i'm
initialized my start angle for the pie
chart as 150 degrees and i'm also giving
shadow to my pie chart so i have
written shadow equal to true
let's run it all right so you can see
here this is my
pie chart that shows you the
distribution of the
male and female
participation
so for male it is 72.5 percent for
female so far it is
27.5 percent as per the data set that we
have
now you can change this start angle to
let's say 180 degree
and it will
change the pie chart to this direction
cool
now moving ahead
this time
we are going to find the total number of
medals that the athletes have won
so i'll use my
data frame athletes underscore df dot
and then my column that is
middle i'll say dot
value
underscore counts
let's run it there you go so you can see
the gold medals the bronze medals and
the silver medals are
very much
similar to each other the numbers are
pretty much the same
all right
now it's time to focus on the total
female athletes who have taken part in
each
olympics
so i'll create a variable
called
female underscore participants
i'll say equal to and then use my data
frame name that is athletes underscore
df
using
square brackets
i'll say
athletes
underscore df
dot
the gender should be equal to equal to
female
and
i'll use ampersand
i'll say
just copy this
paste it here
lc dot
season
equal to equal to we'll check for summer
olympics
and i want to extract only
the gender column so here it is sex
comma
my year column which is here
okay
and then
i'll say
female
underscore
participants
equal to
i'll just copy this
paste it here
and then
i'll use the group by function
say group by which is part of the pandas
library
i'll say year
and then i want to find the count
i'll reset the index
say
reset underscore
index
is a function
and finally we are going to print
female underscore participants
and let's say the head
all right
so what we are trying to do is i am
trying to filter
my data only for the female athletes
for summer olympics
and here
i am printing
the participation
based on each year so i am finding out
the count
so here we need to add
one more square bracket
all right
now we'll
run it and see the result there you go
so you can see here from 1900 1904
all these years you can see the female
participation
let me change it to tail so that we have
the recent data of the olympics
you can see it here for the beijing
olympics 5816
women athletes participated in 2012
london olympics we had
5815 olympics similarly for
the 2016 rio olympics we had
more participation than the london
olympics so 6 23
women athletes had participated
all right
now here
this is another way in which you can
filter your
data for female athletes so i'm
using two parameters my gender should be
equal to female and season
is summer olympics let me just run it i
have stored it in a variable called
women olympics
now
here i am trying to
find a
count plot or i am trying to create a
count plot using my cbon sns library
i have set my style to dark grid
then my figure size i have given as
20 comma 10
my count plot will have the x axis
as year the data is women olympics
and palette i'm using as spectral
and then i have given a title women
participation
let's run and see the output
there you go if i scroll down you can
see on the top i have the title for my
count plot which says women
participation and on the y-axis i have
the count
and at the bottom you can see the
different year values from 1900 till
2000
and 2016 had the highest number of
female participation
cool
let me scroll down so in this cell of
code we are trying to plot a line graph
let me run it and show you the output
so this line graph shows the trend
which says plot for female athletes over
time
so here you can see the line graph so
gradually
the women participation has increased in
olympics since
its inception
there was a slight decrease here this is
around
1950s
and again you can see here there's a
decrease with the women participation in
1980 but since then since 1980 there has
been continuous
increase in the participation of female
athlete numbers cool now coming to the
next section
of our analysis
now we are going to filter the data to
see the details of the athletes who have
won gold medals
so
i'll create a variable called gold
medals
it's equal to i'll use my
data frame as
athletes underscore df
and
within parenthesis i'll use my data
frame name
which is
athletes
underscore
df
dot i'll use the condition middle equal
to equal to
and my value would be gold
next
i'm going to
say gold medals dot head
let's run it
there you go
so here
we have the
top five rows of the athletes who have
won
a gold medal you can see
all the
records have medal as gold
now we are going to use this
subset
of the data and perform some more
analysis
so here
i want to take only the values that are
different from nan so i'm going to use
is
finite
function and inside that i have said
gold medals age
let me just run it cool
now i want to see
the athletes who have
secured a gold medal beyond the age of
60 years
which is very rare
so we'll see the total number of
athletes with more than 60 years of age
having won a gold medal
so here i'm going to say
gold medals
i'll use my
column as id
and then
i'll use
my variable
gold medals
and then
i'll say
age
should be
greater than
60
and then
close my square bracket and say count
okay let me just verify if everything is
fine
yeah
i'll run it
and we'll see the result so there are
total
six athletes who have won a gold medal
having aged more than 60 years
cool
now let me check
for which
sport these six gold medals have come
so i'll say
sporting underscore event
this is going to be my variable name
equal to
i'll use the
same variable name gold medals
i'll going to choose
my sport column
and then
i'll give my
condition
age
greater than
60.
now let's go ahead and
we'll print
the variable spotting event
if i run this you can see it here
so
for art competitions
even for archery and suiting and this
one called rook
we have had gold medals from athletes
who had
an age
more than 60 years
now we are going to plot
this result or the table that we
achieved on the top
so
i'll say plt dot
figure
i'll give my
figure size
equal to let's say 10 comma 5
then
i'll say plt dot
we'll use the
tight layout
say tight underscore
layout
i am going to use the c bond library and
create a count plot
for my variable
sporting underscore
event
then i'll say plt dot
title
i'll give the title as
gold medals
for
athletes
over
60 years of age
let's run it
and if i scroll down you can see here we
have a nice count plot i have my title
gold medals for athletes over 60 years
and since
for archery we had
three players who secured a gold medal
having an age more than
60 years
you can see here archery is three at
competition one
rock is one and shooting we had
one medal
all right
now
we'll see the total gold medals
from each country
so for that
i'll say
gold
medals
dot
will use the
region column
and
followed by that i'll use the
value underscore
counts function
and
i'll reset the index
with name
equal to i'll provide the
middle column
then we are going to print the
head for the top five
countries let me run it you can see it
here
so
usa
has secured the most number of gold
medals then we have russia germany uk
and then we have italy
cool
now in this cell i am going to create a
plot to
visualize the table that i got
above
so i have used my labels my titles i am
using the cat plot function that is
present in the c bond library i have my
x axis my y axis the data which is total
gold medals
let me just verify
okay
and we'll run it
i scroll down
you can see this is a different palette
that i had used which is a rocket
and you can see
usa has got the
most number of gold medals then we have
russia germany uk
italy and france now we also have
included france here which was not
present in the stable the reason being i
have used head
as six
so it will give me the top six countries
all right
now we will analyze
and look at the data for the most recent
olympic event that is present in our
data set i am talking about the 2016 rio
summer olympics
so first of all i'll create a variable
called max year
which will be equal to my data frame
name athletes underscore df
my column name year and i'll use the max
function
then
let's go ahead and print my max here
i'll just show you the output you can
see here my max here present in the data
set is 2016 the rio olympics
next
we will
create another variable called team
underscore names
that will be equal to
my
data frame name athletes underscore df
within square brackets i'll give
parenthesis and then say
athletes underscore df
dot
year
should be
equal to equal to
my
output that is max here
which is actually 2016.
and then i'll say
ampersand
i'll just copy this
we'll paste it here
this time i'll use the
middle column and c equal to equal to
gold
i'll say dot
team
then i'll say team
underscore names dot
value
underscore
counts
dot head
and we'll display the
top
10
countries
let me run this
there you go
so in geo olympics
united states secured the most number of
gold medals
now the reason this is 137 is we have
also counted
the team events for example basketball
similarly great britain had 64 gold
medals in total
russia 50 we have brazil 34 argentina 21
france 20 and japan 17.
all right
now
using the above result we are going to
create a bar plot i'll just change the
steam underscore list to team underscore
names
similarly here also i'll make the
corrections as
team underscore names
cool
now we'll run it
and you can see here we have a nice
horizontal
bar plot so we have united states at the
top
great britain russia germany china
brazil
so here i am displaying the top
20 nations since i've used head
as 20
so these are the top 20 nations who
secured the
most number of gold medals in the u.
olympics
alright
now in the final section of this video
we will create a scatter plot to
visualize the height and weight of male
and female athletes who have won a medal
now it can be a gold medal a silver
medal or a bronze medal
but before that
we
need to filter the data only for
athletes who have won a medal
now if you
had noticed here our
medals column also had a few
null values so we are not going to
consider
those null values here
we are only going to consider for the
athletes who have verna medal
so for that i'll create a
variable called not underscore null
underscore
medals
equal to i'll say
athletes underscore
df
then
i'll give my
let's make it df
i'll give my condition
let me just copy this
i'll paste it here
and then
i'll give my condition
height
and use the
not
null
function
and then i'll say
ampersand
create another parenthesis i'll say
athletes underscore df
this time we'll consider the
weight column
again i'll use the function as not null
and
i'll close the parenthesis
okay i had missed one s here cool
let me just run it now
all right
now we are going to create our final
plot i'll say plt dot figure
i'll give my
figure size
equal to
i'll say 12 comma 10.
i'll say
access
equal to
sns dot
we'll be creating a scatter plot to plot
the
height and weight of the athletes who
have won a medal
i'll say scatter plot
in my x-axis i'll have
height
comma
in my y-axis i'll have
weight
comma
my data should be
not underscore null underscore
medals
so this is what we created here not
underscore null underscore medals
comma
i'll use hue equal to my
sex column
cool
finally i'll say plt dot i'll give a
title to my plot
saying
height
versus
weight
of
olympic
medalists
cool
now let's see our scatter plot
this might take some time to
keep the result because there are so
many athletes present in a data set who
have won a medal and also we are
filtering
in terms of
hue which is for male and female
there you go
so if i scroll down you can see here
we have a nice scatter plot
on the top you have the title of the
plot saying height versus wheat of
olympic medalist you can see
our age as the hue
so blue points are for the male athletes
and orange points are for the female
athletes
and on the y-axis we have the weight in
terms of
kilograms and you have the height in
terms of centimeters
cool
so that brings us to the end of this
demo session on
olympics
dataset analysis
so we used two datasets to
[Music]
carry out this exploratory data analysis
and we
created some
visualizations to analyze and visualize
the data
all right
so that brings us to the end of this
video tutorial on olympics data set
analysis
indian premier league that is ipl is one
of the most popular and exciting events
in world cricket
ipl 2022 will begin on 26th of march so
it's the best time for us and our
viewers to learn about how to perform
exploratory data analysis using the
recently held ipl auction data set so in
this video all the results and insights
that you will see are totally based on
the data we have collected from kegel we
will leave a link to the data set in the
description of the video you can go
ahead and download it
for this demo we'll be using python and
jupyter notebook to answer specific
questions
so let's get started we'll move over to
our jupyter notebook
okay so i'm on my jupyter notebook and
this is the file that we are going to
use so here you can see i have
some of the cells already filled in
so this will save us some time and we
can
explore this data set in depth so this
is the file that i'll be using or the
ipython notebook
cool
so first let's go ahead and import all
the crucial libraries that will be
needed for our analysis so here you can
see i'm importing the pandas library the
numpy library these are for data
manipulation and numerical computation
then we have c bond and matplotlib for
data visualization
then
i have imported this warnings
module
so that we do not get any warnings while
running the code cool
so let me just hit shift enter to run
the first cell
so here we will import
all the libraries okay it's done
now the next step is i'm going to create
a data frame in the name of ipl
and here i'm importing the data set
using the read underscore csb function
which is part of the pandas library so
pd here has been imported as pandas i am
giving the
data set location followed by the name
of the data set so here the name is ipl
underscore 2022 underscore data set dot
csv is the extension of the file
so let me go ahead and run this as well
all right so now we have
successfully imported or loaded our data
set
now the next step let's go ahead and
explore our
data set so i'll use the head function
for this
ipl dot head
okay so here you can see the different
columns we have
an unnamed column which is actually
unnecessary for our analysis so we'll
see how to drop this column apart from
that we have the name of the players the
base price at which the
player was sold or whether the player
was a draft pick so here rasit khan from
afghanistan pandya then we have
subman gil these are all
draft pick and then we have the
price at which
the players were listed in the ipl
auction then we have the type of player
whether the player is a bowler an
all-rounder a batsman
or
a wicketkeeper
then we have the cost in rupees this is
in crores so basically this column tells
us the
price at which the player was sold in
the auction
then we have the price or the cost in
dollars
after that we have
2021 squad basically
this means
in last year's ipl where was the player
so here you can see rasith khan was
playing
for srh the sunrises hyderabad in 2021
but this year in 2022 he'll be playing
for gujarat titans similarly hardik
pandya was playing for mumbai indians
for past few seasons including 2021
but this season is going to play for
gujarat titans
so on and so forth
now
let's see the total number of players
that are present in the data set and the
total columns that are there for this
i'm going to use
the shape attribute so i'll write ipl
dot shape you can see here there are
total 633 players that were part of the
auction and this includes the players
who were draft pick also and there are
total
eight columns in my data frame ipl
next
let's use the info function to check the
columns the data types and the total
non-null objects so i'll say
ipl dot info which is a function so i
have to use
brackets
there you go so here you can see it says
total 633 entries from 0 to 632
data columns we have total eight columns
and then these are the
different
column names and
here you can see the total
normal objects
present in the
column
and here you can see the data types
and at the bottom you can see the
memory usage as well
cool
now
the dot columns attribute will return
the name of the columns in the
data set so if i say ipl dot columns and
run it it will give me
all the different column names that are
present in the data frame
now as i said
the first column which is unnamed
colon 0 is
actually unnecessary so we are going to
drop it for that
we are going to use the
dot drop function and then i have passed
in my
column name followed by the axis on
which access is it there and then i say
in place equal to true which means it
will
replace
and permanently remove
the unnamed column from the data frame
so let's run it and now we'll again
check
the head of the data frame you can see
before we had the
unnamed column which was the first
column in the data frame and now we have
successfully removed it so player
becomes the first column in the data
frame
all right
now moving ahead
let's see the total number of null
values that are present in each column
of the data set so i'll say
ipl dot i'm going to use the is null
function
followed by this sum function
if i run this you can see here
the player column doesn't have any null
values
similarly base price and type column
also don't have any null values but you
can see cost and rupees and
cost in dollars have
nearly 396
missing or null values the reason being
those players were not
picked in the
ipl auction and hence there was no price
associated
and then you can see there were a few
players who were not part of the ipl
squad in 2021
so
those are being reflected as null as
well
now we'll check the
rows that have
cost in dollar as null or nan so here i
have
used ipl and after that i'm passing in
the column name which is cost in dollars
and then i've used the is null function
if i run this
you can
notice the
cost in
dollars column all these values are any
n or
null
and even the same
rows have
nan for
cost in rupees as well cool
now the
next task is to
fill these
null values or nan values with
zeros so for that i'm going to use the
fill any function and here i have passed
in 0 so all the null values in the data
set will be replaced with 0
for
cost in
rupees column and
cost in dollars column
let me just run it all right
okay
now
we will see the players who were unsold
in the 2021 auction which means
we will check the rows that have null
values for the 2021 squad column
so what i'll do is i'll say
ipl
within
square brackets i'll say ipl and then
i'll pass in my
column name which is 2021 squad
and then after this i'll say dot
is null
so
this
cell
will give us
the unsold players in the 2021 auction
if i run this
you see here
you mark the 2021 squad column all these
players were unsold or did not
participate so hence it has any n values
all right
now what we are going to do is
we will replace all the null values
that are present in the
2021 score column with
not participated
like how we did in the previous example
we replaced all the null values with 0
here we'll replace with
a text value called not participated so
i'll say ipl
i'll pass in my column name which is
2021 squad
equal to
i'll say
ipl
2021
squad
dot
fill
any
which is the function and here i'll pass
in a
text or a string saying not
participated
all right
let's run it
before that let me just scroll it down
now i'll run it cool
now that we have treated the null value
successfully let's verify it again so
i'll just say ipl
dot
is null
and then i'm going to use this sum
function
if i run this okay this is also a
function cool now if you see we have
successfully removed all the null values
and replaced with either zeros or not
participated and hence now you can see
none of the
columns in the ipl data frame have null
value so it shows 0.
great
now moving ahead
now we are going to add another column
called
status
which will hold two values sold and
unsold
but before that
we are going to
slice
our data frame so here i am looking for
all the rows where
cost and rupees
is greater than
0
and those should be unique and
i am storing the value in a variable
called teams so here you can see we have
the different teams where the
cost in rupees is greater than zero
now
i'm going to create
another
column called status so i have written
ipl
within square brackets i am passing in
the column name which is status and
that will be equal to
the team
replaced by
sold value
let me just run it and show you the
result there you go
so here you can see we have added a new
column called status and it has values
sold
and unsold
if i just say ipl
at the bottom you can see
the unsold values as well
cool
now in the next cell
we are going to check for duplicated
players so there are duplicate rows in
the data frame but here the names of the
players are same but in reality the
players are different
so
it is quite understood that
different players can have the same name
so to get those names i am using the
duplicated function and i'll say keep
equal to false which means i don't want
to keep those players
now let's run it
there you go so here you can see lalitha
we have
two entries so lalithyadev here is an
all rounder whose base price was 20 lakh
for 2022 ipl
and
last year
he was playing for the delhi capitals
and this year also
he is
sold
to delhi capitals
next we have
lalithyadev who happens to be a bowler
so this is again different lalitha
so last year
he was unsold and even this year he
remains unsold
similarly we have amit mishra
who earlier used to play with the delhi
capitals but this time he remains unsold
so on and so forth so you can see two
entries for subham shrink as well and
shivam
all right
now
let's answer a very basic question
we are going to find out how many
players
have participated
in the 2022 ipl auction
for that we have already seen
the total number of rows that were
present but again i'm going to use the
shape function and within
square brackets i'm going to say 0 which
means it will give me the total number
of rows
and you can see 633 players were part of
the auction this is as per our data that
we have collected from kegel
up next we are going to find
how many types of players have
participated
so i'm going to say
types equal to
say ipl
i'll use the column name which is type
and i'm going to find the
count of
each type of players that are present in
the data frame
i'm going to use the values underscore
counts function
and then i'll say
type
dot
reset underscore index
if i run it
okay there is an error here let me debug
the error
okay so this should be value underscore
counts and
the variable name is types are not type
so let's run it
you can see here
we have the different
types of players so all rounders there
are total 242 all down those are part of
the auction then we have 215 bowlers 112
batsmen's and 64 wicket keepers
now using the above
table that we just created
i'm going to
plot my first
pie chart
so for that i'm going to use the
matplotlib pi function so plt.pi
i'm using
types.values since i want only the
values from this table
and then
i am saying labels equal to types dot
index
i have used a label distance of 1.2 to
maintain some space and then this is my
format in which i want to
print or show or display the percentage
of
distribution i am going to use shadow so
it says shadow equal to true which is
another parameter or an argument and
then i'm going to start my angle at 60
degrees
and here i've used a title called rule
of players participated
that will have a font size of 15 and
finally i'm saying plt dot plot
so let me just run it
there you go so here we have a nice
pie chart or a pie plot so you can see
the different pies here
we have all rounder wicket keeper
batter and bowler
so majorly
there are all-rounders in the auction
followed by bowlers then we have 17.69
percent batters and 10.11 percent
wicketkeepers which is the lowest
cool
now
we are going to create another bar plot
or a bar graph that will tell us how
many players were sold and unsold so for
this i am going to use a count plot so
we will create two bars one for
sold and the other one for unsold and
each of the bars will have different
colors
one will have orange the other one will
have pink and i am using labels so to
label the x-axis and y-axis i have sold
or unsold by label will have number of
players the title of my bar graph would
be sold versus unsold i've given a font
size of 15 and i'm saying
plt.plot
now the function that you see here at
the bottom
will display the data labels for each of
the bars
let me just run it and show you the
result there you go
so i have used a figure size of 10 comma
5
all right now you can see we have a
really good
bar plot which says there were total 237
players sold and 396 players were unsold
as per the data we have
cool
now
you can also
print the total sold and unsold values
let me show you how to do it
i'll say ipl
dot we can use the group by function
and i want to group it by
status column
and
the value that i want to measure is
the player's
count
so i'll say players
rather player and then i'm going to use
the
count function if i run this you can see
here
i've successfully grouped the unsold and
sold players the values are matching
with
the bar plot that we just created so
sold where 237 players are on sold are
396.
cool
now
we are going to see the total number of
players bought by each team again this
is going to be a count plot so basically
a bar plot
so here the condition i'm passing is
in the teams column the value shouldn't
be unsold
so
players bought means the value should be
sold so here i am using this condition
and the rest of the things remains the
same
one improvement
i have done here is i am using x sticks
rotation equal to 70 degrees this
basically means the x labels would be
tilted by 70 degrees
now let's see
the bar plot there you go so here you
can see i have the title players bought
by each team on the y-axis we have the
number of players
and on the x axis you can see the values
have been tilted by
70 degrees let me just zoom in so that
you can see better
and this is the bar plot so the maximum
a team can purchase is 25 players some
of the teams have also purchased 24 22
and 23 players let me just
show you so
gujarat titans have totally purchased 22
players
then
delhi capitals have total 24 players in
their squad
again
lucknow supergiants have 22 players
if i scroll and see again
bangalore loyal challengers or rcb
they're all challenges bangalore have
22 players in the team
and rajasthan royals and sunrises
hyderabad have
24 and 23 players respectively in their
teams
all right
now
we will create three more columns
called
retention
base price
and base price unit
for that
first of all i am creating a new column
called retention which is equal to
ipl base price let me just run it
and then
i'm going to replace
these values that are present in the
list 2 crore 40 lakh 20 lakh 1 crore 30
lakh 1.5 crore
with
from auction
and i'm saying in place equal to true
let me just run it
then we are going to
treat the base price
so here
in the base price
column i'm going to replace
draft pick value as 0 so let's run that
as well
and now
i am going to split
the base price
value into two separate values called
bree spice unit and base price so
basically i am splitting
on this piece
that i have let me show you how it is
going to split
so this is let's see our
base price column
what i did was i
replaced the draft pick values to 0
and then the rest of the values will be
split into two columns called base price
unit so basically it will have the
unit
of the base price let's say crores or
lakhs
and
the base underscore price column will
have the value which is 2 here 40
20 20 so on and so forth
let me just scroll down
and
run that particular cell
now to create
these two columns the base price unit
column and the base underscore price
column i have used the lambda function
and i'm splitting based on the space
let's just run it
now i have replaced
retained with zero
and
let me show you the
final data frame that i have
so here you can see we have replaced
the draft pick values in the base price
column to zero
and on the right side you can see the
three different columns that i wanted to
create
so one is called retention
so zeros refer to draft pick any other
value will say
the player was picked from the auction
then you have the base price
unit so here
you can see crores
lacks and the value base price is 2
40 so on and so forth
cool
choose from over 300 in demand skills
and get access to 1 000 plus hours of
video content for free visit skillup by
simplylearn click on the link in the
description to know more
now
let's check how many players were
retained and bought from the auction by
each of the teams
so i'll say
ipl let me just scroll down
dot
i'm going to use the
group by function
then i'll say
team
comma
retention
then i am going to
use the value
as
retention because i want to find the
count of
retained players
then i'll say colon
-1
let me run it you can see here
the different team names because i have
grouped by team and then retention so i
have changed super kings
from the auction they had picked
21 players and they had retained
four players
coming to delhi capitals delhi capitals
in the 2022
ipl auction they picked total 20 players
and they have retained four similarly if
i scroll down let me talk about let's
say punjab kings they have
picked 23 players from the auction and
retained two players from
the team last year
talking about
rcb or all challenges bangalore they
have picked 19 players from the auction
and they have retained
three players
all right
now in the next cell of code
we are going to display the players in
each team
based on the different types of players
so let me just run it and show you the
result
so here i am using the same condition
the value shouldn't be equal to
unsold
and i am going to use another parameter
called hue for the different colors so
here
i have used hue
as type because i want to
show the players in each team based on
the different types
again i have given my
title to the bar plot
and then i have the x label the y label
and my rotation is 50 degrees now
if i scroll down you can see the
different types of players here is the
legend so blue is for buller
orange or yellow
it's for all rounder green is for batter
and red
which also looks like maroon is for
wicket keepers
and on the
x-axis you can see the different team
names
all right
now let's answer another
couple of questions so here i have
what is the highest amount spent on a
single player by each team
so to solve this question i'll say
my data frame name that is ipl
then i'm going to say
retention
equal to equal to
this should be from
auction because you want to see the
highest amount spent and not
from the retained players
then i'm going to
group
by
i'll say
team
and then
i'll say
cost
in
let me just copy it from here
cost in rupees
that is in cross
and
i'll say
max
colon
minus 1
dot
sort underscore
values
i'll say ascending
equal to false which means i want the
sorted
result in descending order
okay
let me just
bring this
to the left side and we'll run it
there seems to be some error let me
check the error it sees
there's a spelling mistake this should
be
team
let me run it again there you go
so you can see
mumbai indians
have spent
15.25 crores
for one of the players and
this player happens to be sean kissen
then
chennai super kings have spent the
highest amount for
a player who happens to be a bowler the
name is deepak chahar they have bought
him for 14 crores kolkata knight riders
bought shreyas ayer for 12.25 crores
and so on and so forth
so these are the highest amounts spent
on a single player by each of the teams
let me scroll down
now we are going to see the player
retained at
maximum value or maximum price
now if you follow ipl the maximum
price
at which a player was retained happens
to be ravindra jadeja so let's see at
what price was he retained
i'll say
retention
equal to equal to i'll say
retained
then i'll say
sort underscore
values
by equal to i'll use the
same column
cost in
rupees
that's in crores
i'll say
ascending equal to
false
dot
head
and i want to find the top player
again there's some error
let's see
where is the error
this is ascending equal to false
dot head
okay this should be
sort underscore
values
within bracket i should say
buy
i think this should be
fine now let's run it
there you go
so you can see here our result is player
name ravindra jadeja who was retained
for 16 crores by chennai super kings
cool
now
the next cell of code will
display or print the top five bowlers
who have been picked
in this year's ipl based on
their cost in inr
let me just run it and show you the
result
you can see here deepak chahar went for
14 crores then we have shraddha thakur
who was bought by
delhi capitals earlier he was part of
csk
for
10.75 crores then we have prasada
krishna who has been bought by rajasthan
royals this time
last year he was with keker and he has
been bought for 10 crores similarly loki
ferguson has been bought by gujarat
titans
and he played for kkr last season he has
been bought for 10 crores while his base
price was too close then we have aavish
khan
you can see avishkhan's base price was
just 20 lakhs and he has been bought for
10 crores by lucknow super giants again
and last year he was part of the delhi
capitals
now you can replace
this value
suppose let's say you want to find the
top five batsman's picked or batters
picked with the highest amount you can
just see
batter instead of bowler and if i run
this
you can see here
surya sayer was bought by
kolkata nitriders for 12.25 crores last
year he was part of delhi capitals
then you have
shimmerin hate maya who's from
west indies he has been
picked by the rajasthan royals for
8.5 crores then we have rahul tripathi
sikha dhavan and that particle
now if you wanted to check for
let's say all rounders
you can replace batter with all rounder
if i run this
you can see
lamb living stone has been bought by
punjab kings this season
for
11.5 crores his base price was just one
crore and last year he was part of the
rajasthan royals
then we have a player from sri lanka
asuranga then we have hershel patel
shahrukh khan and rahul devatia who have
been
the top five all-rounders picked at
highest amount
cool
now finally
we want to
see the players who were part of the ipl
last season but were not picked for this
year's ipl
so for that what i'm doing is first i'm
renaming my
2021 squad column
this column i want to
rename it as previous team
let's run it
then
i am going to find out the unsold
players so here i am saying previous
team not equal to
not participated
and then
i am using another condition the team
should be equal to equal to unsold and i
am going to find out only the player and
the previous team
so let's run it and see the result
so here you can see
these players were part of the ipl last
season but
they haven't been picked this season
and last season they had played for
let's say suresh shrine i played for csk
steve smith was part of the delhi
capitals sakupalhassan
was part of kkr if i scroll down you
have david milan who played for punjab
kings in 2021
ein morgan
who played for kkr he also captained kkr
but unfortunately he was
not picked this season chris lane from
australia also
remained unsold this season and to tie
we have been cutting aditya
there are other players as well
we have kane richardson dhawal kulkarni
cool so these were the players who are
part of the ipl season 2021 but
unfortunately but not pegged and
remained unsold for 2022 season
cool
and that brings us to our
end of this demo session on
ipl data analysis 2022 so we learned
how to
use the different functions
and attributes that are part of
the
python libraries and we manipulated the
data we visualized the data and
answered some specific questions
in this video we'll be using four
publicly available data sets about
formula one that has information from
1950 to the 2019 f1 season
we'll see how using the python libraries
you can perform exploratory data
analysis and draw valuable insights
so let's begin by understanding what
formula 1 is
formula one also known as f1 is a motor
sport defined by open wheeled single
seat race cars
it features the best drivers in the most
powerful and technically advanced cars
the sport is governed by the fia that is
international automobile federation
here 10 teams comprising of two drivers
each compete in a series of races over a
period of one year to find out the
ultimate driver and a constructor
champion
in our demonstration we'll be using four
data sets let me show them one by one
these are all csv files
now this is the first data set that
we'll be using in our demo so if you
notice the data set does not have
columns names in fact none of the data
sets have column names so while
importing the data set we will assign
the column names using the names
parameter
i'll show that in a
while
now this is the results data set
the results data set has information
about
the result id
then we have the race id driver id
we have
the constructor id
grid position
then we also have information about the
fastest
lap then we also have information about
rank
the fastest lap speed
and the status id
now moving on to the second data set
which is about
races
now this is the second data set which is
about races so
it has information about the race id the
year in which the race was held then we
have the round number circuit id
then the name of the
grand prix so you can see here australia
and malaysia and chinese spanish monaco
turkish british german
and others
then we have the
date on which the gp was held or the
gone pre was
held
you have the time
and the url which basically leads to the
wikipedia page of that particular
grand prix for that year
now moving on to our third data set
so this is our third data set which is
about
drivers
now it has the driver id the name of the
driver you can see here hamilton
rossberg alonso
ryken
then we have sato
masa
button weber and all
after that we have the
number code
then we have the
phone name of the driver the surname of
the driver
and then we have the date of birth of
that particular driver we have the
nationality as well
we have the wikipedia page
for the
driver
now moving on to the last data set which
is about
constructors
so this is the fourth and the final data
set that we'll be using in our data
analysis project so here we have the
constructor id
then the constructor reference
in formula one
and this is the actual name of the
constructor so we have mclaren
we have
bmw sauber williams then we have ferrari
toyota red bull force india
we also have jordan jaguar and all
next we have the
nationality and the url
that is the wikipedia page of
that particular constructor
now let's head over to our jupyter
notebook and we'll start with our
analysis
here is my jupyter notebook that i'll be
using for this demo you can see some of
the cells are already filled this is
just to make sure we
save some time
so
using these data sets that we just saw
and our libraries such as numpy pandas
matplotlib and c-bond
we'll answer specific questions such as
the drivers and constructors who have
been the most successful throughout the
history of f1
sport then we'll explore the impact of
starting and finishing positions and if
the speed of the cars has changed over
the years
so let's begin with our analysis
first and foremost we are going to
import all the necessary libraries so
here i am importing numpy pandas
matplotlib and cbon
and after that i am writing percentage
matplotlib inline
that is to ensure that
all the plots are embedded in line i'll
hit shift enter to run it
take some time there you go so we have
successfully imported all the libraries
now the next step is to
load the data and assign
column names
so
i'll load my
first data which is results i'll say pd
dot
read underscore
csv
i'll give my
file name which is results.csv
and then using the
names parameter
i'll pass in the
column names so actually i have written
the column names in a notepad let me
open that
so i have this f1
notepad created which has the column
names i'll just start copying
the column names
within the names parameter i'll paste it
if i scroll to the right you can see the
different column names that
have been assigned
and
that
i'm going to say
comma
and i'll write
header equal to
none
i'll close the bracket
cool
similarly let's
import the second data set which is
about
races i'll say
pd dot
read underscore csv
i'll give my
file name which is racist.csv
and then
i'll give the
names parameter this is actually names
and not name
okay
i'm going to
copy the
second line
and i'll paste it here
and again
i'll say
header
equal to
none
next
we'll import our third data set which is
about drivers
so i'll say pd dot read underscore csv
i'll say
drivos.csv
then
again use the
names parameter
and i'll copy the
third line now which has the column
names
for the
drivers data set
here
i
need to give
another parameter which is header
equal to
none
finally we are going to import our
constructors data set
it's a constructors equal to pd dot
read underscore csv which is the
function present in the pandas library
i'll say
constructors.csv which is my
file name
and then again i'll use the names
parameter i'll go to my notepad and this
time i'll copy the
fourth line which has the column names
for the constructors data set
i'll paste it
and
here i'll give my
final parameter that is header equal to
none
all right
now
let me hit shift enter to
run it okay we see some error here let's
debug the error it says
no such file or directory drivers dot
csv
let's see
there was the issue
this should be
driver.csv
cool now we have successfully loaded the
data and assigned the
columns to the various datasets
now the
next analysis
is to merge all the data set
so here i'll create a data frame called
df and i'll use
pd dot
merge function
first i'll use the
results data frame that we just
imported above
this one
and
i'm going to
merge it with
racist data frame
and from the resist data frame i am
going to take
specific columns like the
race id
then
i need the
ear
after that i need
name
next
i'm going to take
the round column as well
and
i'm going to use
on parameter so
on parameter
is actually
the column that is common to both the
data frames that is results and resist
so here my common column
is going to be the race id because it is
present in both the data sets
and i would like to merge
so for that i'm going to use how so i'm
going to use a left join
so
if you know sql you will be aware of
left join it takes all the rows from the
left table and only the matching rows
from the right table
again going to use the merge function so
i'll write
df equal to pd dot
merge
i'll say
df comma and now i'm going to
merge the
divorce data set
and
i'm going to select
specific columns so i'll say
driver id
make sure there are no spelling mistakes
in the
column names
then i'll say
driver
ref which is the name of the driver or
reference
comma
and then i want the
nationality of the
driver
all right
we'll give a comma i'll say on
which column i want to merge so here the
common column
is going to be the driver id
again
how is going to be a left join
going to the final
merge part i'll say again df equal to pd
dot
merge
i'll pass in my data frame and my final
data set which i have is about
constructors
from constructors we are going to choose
specific columns so i'll take the
constructor
id
then
i'll take
the name column
and again the
nationality column of the
manufacturer
here i'll say
on equal to
the common column i'll use this
constructor id
you give a comma and say how
equal to
left again
cool
make sure
you're merging it with the
right column names so let's run this
cell to merge
all the four data sets
i'll hit
click enter
oops there is some error let's see it
says constructor
id index
okay there's a spelling mistake this
should be
constructor id cool
let's run it
there you go
now
the next thing we want to do is to drop
the unnecessary columns
so i'll say df.drop
within the drop function
we are going to pass in the
column names i'll
say number
then we also don't want the
position column
next we have
position underscore
text after that we have
lapse
next we are going to drop
fastest
lap
then we will also drop the
status id
comma
we'll drop the
result underscore id column
then
i'm going to drop the race underscore id
column
we'll also drop
driver underscore id column
and finally we are going to drop
the
constructor underscore id column
and
i'll say access equal to
1
and in place i'll c equal to true
because i want to remove it from my
original data frame that is df
there you go
now the next
thing i want to do is i want to rename
some of the columns so i'll say df dot
rename
i'll say
columns equal to
now we are going to pass in a dictionary
i'm going to change the
rank
to
test
underscore lab underscore rank
let me give a comma
now i'll say name underscore x
equal to
i'll say the
grand prix name so i'll say gp
underscore name
next column i'm going to focus is
the nationality column so i'll say
nationality underscore
x
i'll give a colon the value i'm going to
pass in is
driver nationality
all right
up next
we have one column called
underscore
y
and that i am going to change it to
constructor name
another comma
i'm going to say
nationality
underscore
y
colon
change it to
constructor nationality
underscore nationality
finally we have
driver
underscore ref column
and that i'm going to replace with
just drive off
finally i'll say
in place
equal to true
just verify if all the column names are
correct
let's run it
all right so now we have
successfully renamed
the columns
after that
in the next cell i'm going to rearrange
the columns so here i'm
using the same data frame and we have
just renamed the columns so starting
with your
grand prix name round driver
nationality
and others
let's run this
up next
we're going to drop the
2019 season data because
it is incomplete
so i'll say df equal to
df
then i'll see
here
not
equal to
2090
let's see how to sort the values so i'll
say df equal to df dot
sort underscore values which is the
function name
i'm going to sort it by
here
followed by
round
followed by
the
position underscore
order
comma i'll say
ascending
equal to
first let's say is false
next i have true
and then
i'll have true
all right
moving ahead
now we are going to see how to replace
the
put slash
n values in
the time column with
something called nan because the time
column was not registered when a driver
did not finish a raise or was lab by
another driver
so to do this i am going to say
df dot
time
dot i am going to use the replace
function
and here i will say
forward slash
or backward slash
n
and i'm going to replace with
numpies nan
i'll say
in place equal to true
let me just copy this because we are
going to use the same
emitters
next i'm going to replace the
milliseconds value
milliseconds dot
replace i'll paste it here
then i'll say df dot
fastest
underscore lab underscore
rank dot
replace
paste it
next i have
df dot
fastest dot
lab
dot time
they replace
to that i have
the next column which is
speed so i'll say fastest
underscore
lab underscore
speed
dot
replace
and paste it
so here
i'm going to replace this particular
value
the
backward slash
n with
nan
let me run it
cool
step i'm going to change the data types
for
fastest underscore lab underscore speed
to float then fastest underscore lab
underscore rank to float again
now
problem here is we cannot convert it
into an integer because there are
missing values so we are going to change
it to float
again for milliseconds also we are
changing it to float values
let me run it
now
i'll reset the index
let me show you how to reset the index
i'll say df dot
reset
underscore
index and say
drop
equal to
true
give a comma and say
in place equal to true
all right
that we have
done our initial processing step of the
data set
now we'll check the shape of the data
set then we see all the data sets the
total number of non-null values the
memory usage and we'll
check the head of the data set
now to see the total number of
rows and columns i'll say print
df dot shape
you can see here there are total 24
197 rows in my data set and there are
total of 15 columns
now let's use
df dot
info function
so it gives me the
year the grand prix name
the round number
driver constructor name grid
position order total number of points
time
then time in milliseconds the first slap
rank
the fastest lap speed
the nationality of the driver the
nationality of the constructor
then here we have the
total number of non-null objects
and then you also have the memory usage
at the bottom
finally let's see the
head of the data frame so i'll see
df dot
head let's say i want to check the first
10 rows
the yuko
if i scroll down you can see here we
have the top 10 rows printed
and you have the year the grand prix
name round driver constructor name and
other columns now let me just brief you
about what these column names stand for
so the year column that you see here is
the season that the grand prix took
place and then we have the
name of the grand prix
now the round column is the number of
the race in each season for example one
means it was the first race of the
season and then
two means it was the second race of the
season so so on and so forth
then we have the name of the driver
that we have the
name of the car constructor so you can
see ferrari mercedes red bull renault
then we have the grid that is the
starting position before the race
actually this depends on the
qualifications which occur one day
before the race
then we have the position underscore
order column this means the final
position at the end of the race then we
have the points column that is the total
number of points scored in the race
next we have the time that is the amount
of time that took to finish the race
only the winners time is displayed and
drivers behind the winner are shown how
far behind the winner they are
then we have the milliseconds column
that is the amount of time that took to
finish the race in milliseconds
if i just scroll down
i'll just move to the
right
go to the top
then we have the fastest underscore lab
underscore rank that is the order of the
fastest lab during the race
next we have
fastest lap time that is the shortest
amount of time that took to complete a
lap in the release
then we have the lap speed that is the
average speed of the
fastest lap
then we have the
country to which the driver belongs to
and then we have the
constructor nationality that is the
country where the car constructor is
based out of
okay
now
here i am going to
set my figure size to 10 comma 6 this is
going to be for all the
plots that we are going to create
afterwards
cool
we'll create a data frame that will have
all the grand prix winners
so here i'm going to say
driver
underscore
winner equal to
use my data frame
df dot i'll say
lock then i'll say
df
i want
the position underscore
order
and that should be equal to 1 so which
means
the driver one degrees
and then
i'm going to
use the
group by function
i'm going to group it by
driver
and
for values i'll say
position underscore
order
use the
count function
followed by
sort underscore
values
i'll say
ascending equal to
false
you change it to
to underscore
frame
dot
reset
underscore
index
what essentially i am doing here is i am
finding out
all the drivers that have participated
and
won a grand prix
next
i am going to create a
bar plot so this is going to be the
first visualization of our analysis
so i'll say
sb
which we have taken in our
analysis
ideally it should be sns but sb also
will work
so i'll say sb
dot
bar plot
i'm going to say data equal to
driver underscore
winner
the y-axis i'll have
driver
the x-axis i'll have
position
underscore
order
then i have
color equal to
green
that i'll set my
alpha value
to
0.5
or let's say
0.8
then
we are going to
give a title to our plot so i'll say plt
dot
title let's say most
grand prix
winners in f1
then we are going to label our access so
for y label i will have
driver
name
we have
the x label
that will have
number of
grand prix wins
and i'll say
plt dot
y
ticks
let's run it
and you can see we have our first
bar plot here now the bar plot
shows that there are
a large distribution of
grand prairie vents
only a few drivers in history of f1 have
won over 20 grand pray in their careers
and there are some drivers who
completely dominated the f1 racing and
have won over
50 grand praise in their careers so we
are going to focus on those
top 5 or top 10
drivers
in the next section so what i am doing
here is
from the
above
result that we just got
i'm going to filter out only the top 10
so i am going to use the head function
and
inside that i passed in 10 if i print it
you can see here
as per the data that we have
we have michael schumacher
who
is the position
order leader with 91 gp events then we
have hamilton vettel frost senna
alonso
then we have stevert clerk and louder
the data that we have is
not the most recent one so if you check
the actual stats hamilton has actually
overtaken michael sumacher and has
won over
103 close to 103 releases as of now
and
next we have michael sumacre so this is
not the most recent data
cool
now using this data we'll create another
bar plot for the top 10
drivers so i'll say sb dot
bar plot
i'll say data equal to
the
name that we have used that is top 10
drivers so i'll say top 10
drivers
in the y-axis we'll have
the
driver name
in the x-axis we'll have
position
underscore
order
for the bars i'm going to use a color
equal to
let's say blue this time
i'll set my alpha value
to be
0.8
and
i'll say let's say
line
width
equal to
0.8
and i'll also give
an edge color of let's say black
follow the seam drill i'm going to give
a title to my plot so i'll say plt dot
title
most
gp
winners in f1
will give a y label
that says
driver
name
and then i'll have
x label which will have
number of
on prey bins
cool
let me see if everything is fine
and then we'll
run this there you go
you can see we have a very nice
horizontal
bar plot that shows the
top drivers in f1 so as per our data
that we have we have michael schumacher
who has 1 over 91 or close to
91
races then we have hamilton battle
alonso clark and others
all right
in the same way we are going to create
bar plot for the top constructors that
have participated in f1
so here i am finding out
all the
constructor winners so here
i'm using my position underscore order
equal to equal to 1 and then i'm using
the group by
based on the constructor name
and then i'm finding the count of
position order and sorting the values
in
descending order and i am changing it to
frame or to a data frame
and to create my bar plot i am using the
bar plot function the data which is
constructor underscore winner
in the y-axis i'll have the constructor
name on the x-axis i'll have the
position order
so you can see here i've used color as
pink and i've given a title x label by
label
and vitix
let's run it
there you go so here you can see again
the data is
widely
spread
so we have a lot of constructor names
now our next task is to
check the
top 10 gpa constructor windows so here
i'm using the head function and finding
out the top 10
if i run it
you can see here
the manufacturing companies or the
constructors who have won the most
number of
races
are ferrari
mclaren williams then we have mercedes
red bull tim lotus
renault and others
okay
now we'll convert this data into a
horizontal
bar graph or a bar chart
so that will show the bar plot for the
top 10
constructors
now let me show you how to do it
so i'll say
sb which is for c bond dot
bar plot i'm going to say data equal to
top 10 let me just confirm
the name we have top 10 constructors
scroll down i'll say constructors
y axis i'll have
constructor
on the x-axis i'll have
position underscore order
then
i'll say
color
equal to let's say we'll use the
red color for the bars
then i'll set my
alpha to
0.8
i'll say
line width equal to
0.8
and my
edge color i'll say
black
that i'll say plt dot
title
say
top 10
most
gp
wins
lt dot
by label would be
constructor
name
and i'll have plt dot
x label
as
number of
gp
wins
cool
let's run it
there you go so here you can see we have
ferrari at the top then we have mclaren
williams more cities i'm pretty certain
by
the end of 2021 season mercedes would
have gained a lot of wins
since hamilton
has been on the top
for mercedes for quite some time now
all right
now
finally we are going to
create a
regression plot that will
show how
two variables that is the starting
position and finishing
position
vary
so to do that i am going to exclude the
data points with grid 0 because it skews
the data so 0 means that the driver
started from the
pit lane
so
i'm using this function called reg plot
to plot my
regression line let me run it and show
you the result there you go
so if you see here
we can easily see there is a linear
relationship between the
starting and
finishing position so on the x-axis we
have the starting position on the y-axis
we have the
finishing or the finished place
so which is what is actually expected
right now we can also see that most
races had up to
25 drivers you can see the density of
the points here
but
some of the recess also had over 30
drivers you can see the
light color blue dots
next
we are going to
check whether the speed of the cars
changed over the years since this data
is only available from 2004 onwards so
we have
we have taken
years that start from 2004 onwards
now let me show you the result
of this data
so essentially we are plotting the
average speed amongst
all teams during the fastest lap at
individual grand prix and here on the
y-axis you have the average fastest
speed in kilometer per hour and then you
have the different
gps
and
you can see here the year values
now
in general what we see is there's a
decrease in the average fastest lap from
2004
till around
2015
for almost all the circuits
and again from 2015 onward the speeds
started
to increase
you can see here there's an increase
after 2015 there's an increase there's
an increase here as well
you can also notice that
the speed is very different on each
track for instance if you check the
italian grand prix which is here
italian gp has the
fastest race in the calendar with
average speed exceeding over 240
kilometers per hour on the other hand if
you
talk about the
monaco grand prix let me show you if you
see here
the monaco gp is the slowest race with
average speed below
160 kilometer per hour now this is
actually expected because the monaco
grand prix
has very narrow streets and
hence the drivers cannot
drive fast in this circuit
all right hey everyone welcome to this
interesting video in javascript
the best way to master a language is by
programming in it if you enjoy watching
such tech videos make sure to subscribe
to our channel and hit the bell icon to
never miss an update
so what's in store for you
we'll first create some simple beginner
level projects like how to build a
calculator app
then we'll move on to more advanced apps
like the weather app
the tic-tac-toe game
and finally we'll conclude the session
by creating a snake game application
now i'm sure you're excited to dive deep
into it so let's begin so we have
decided to basically develop very
interesting project in javascript that
is known as calculator application
like you have seen earlier some projects
like in tic-tac-toe you talk about snake
game you talk about quiz application
this time we're going to introduce you
another very interesting project using
this javascript html css so called
calculator application so let's get
started let me try to delete first those
files which we really do not need it now
uh
we delete this all
yeah now i'll be creating a new folder
now and give the name called
calculator app
and in this calculator app once again we
need some new files which is called
index
dot html
and we also need one more that is called
app.css
and another one that is called app dot
js
so these three files required now first
of all i would start with
index.html5 where we will be creating a
template of my code
now
let me go and create this template and
here
i have a god body with me
let's start with the
first
tag here that is called h1
and this h1 we are giving the name
called calculator
calculator
so that will be my h1 heading
after that we'll start working with the
div tag
now within this div
i would have to create lot many classes
i may not have lot many css classes but
we can give some classes here so we can
say class equal to
container
okay
so within this div tag we're going to
create a table now because i want to
organize it
so starting with the table within this
table
tr tag
and within this tr tag i need a td
now in this td i need few things call
call
span
equal to three
another value
and here i want to offer the textbox
input type equal to
text
okay input text id equal to get the name
called result
that will be the final outcome while
pressing all the different buttons i
equal to result and
class
equal to
screen remember i haven't created those
css classes bus but we're giving some
names but later on we can utilize it
while creating those css classes
table data is getting closed let's get
started with another td
now insert this td we need another text
box
input type equal to
text
and
here in this input text sorry i would
like to better say button because i'll
be having
buttons
okay
input
button
value
equal to
c
and one click
equal to i may not have any function
right now but yes i can create
a function but let me give some domain
name here
i'm saying clear
screen
okay so that will be the function will
get called
and after that class
equal to
clear
yeah so this is my button tag
after this our td tag is getting closed
after the td tag the table row is also
getting closed
after the table row
which is getting close we're going to
start working with another
table okay and in this table row i'm
gonna create one more td
so let's go ahead and create
another td here
and inside this td i'll be having
another projector we get created
so i'll just say
this is another button now input equal
to button value equal to
one on click equal to i'll be calling
another function called display
okay and inside this we're giving the
value call 1
okay and class equal to member
class equal to
number
and here after that tag is getting
closed
okay now we have to start another td tag
here
okay like that we have to keep on
creating the multiple buttons so let me
copy
and paste another table data
now here
again value equal to 2 on click product
display
give the value call 2
and class equal to what
number
like that i'll keep on creating multiple
buttons but first check how it actually
looks like
now i can see the buttons like in c123
but yes i'm going to create few more
buttons one after another
okay so i'll go here
and create
few more buttons so this is where the
table data is getting closed
okay i'll copy this
and paste it again
i have to create
the button
like in
3 4 something like that
so after this two we're giving the value
called three
here
i'll give the value call 3
so val equal to 2 value equal to 3
display 3
and then afterwards
just giving the value call
forward slash
and here also we're going to keep the
value called
forward slash
and here class equal to
operator
operator
after that you have to do the value call
4
and then followed by five six seven
so here we give four
four
five
five
six
six
after six we're giving for minus
[Music]
okay once again it will be what type of
operator
operator
okay after this minus we'll be talking
about call seven
then we have to have eight
okay nine
okay after that we're giving call plus
and
display
plus plus equal to operator
operator okay so here
you can see the table data is getting
closed and here the table is also
getting closed and after the stable row
we can start working with
another table over here
and
after this table row we can start
working with again
td let me have this
again
inside this i'll be giving the option
called decimal which is value equal to
dot and here we get the value called
decimal
okay
now display zero
so after giving this dot to basically
take what the value
zero which we haven't put now
we'll be talking about value called zero
so here
the decimal value we have given it td is
getting close let me have the other one
zero
zero
so like that we have to keep this now
after that
we'll be once again
taking this
this time rather than giving this zero
we'll be using this call as a button
and value equal to equal
or click equal to
solve
okay and then this soft will not be
passing anything
it will write a normal function
and plus equal to
equal
okay
so
table data is getting closed
so we will be using another table data
now
so here it will be the button only
okay we will be using
well equal to multiplication
display
plastic and here we'll be using operator
okay
so table data is getting close table is
getting close table is also getting
closed here
okay so your div tag is also getting
closed here
okay that's it
okay so that's the only thing which we
wanted to make let me try to refresh and
check
awesome
so we have got
all those
necessary calculator behavior
which
we wanted to
reveal
okay
now our next statement will be once
we're giving this c then we have to call
one two three
and then forward slash
followed by
four five six will come down
okay so let me check whether we have
used six or not
okay so we haven't used six
so let me check here
four five six
so let me go back here
four five six let me copy this
and paste it later on
before
minus
six
equal to
num
okay so we're almost set now
so we are having this
look and feel
in this we are giving one two three four
five six
and after this we have a call minus and
then plus related behavior so we are all
set now and after that we'll be
basically applying the css as well as
the javascript look towards my code okay
thank you
well everybody we are all good to go now
but i just want to first check whether
my
this outlook is looking properly or not
see what my expectation is after one two
three forward slash i really want to
bring four five six to the next
and then seven eight nine and again
forward but i can think this is
absolutely unorganized
so after this when we say this forward
slash which we have used after hyphen
okay your td is getting closed here
okay so here the tr i also want to close
here
okay and after this tr i also want to
start
another tr here
okay so that i can put them into the
another level now so under this tr i can
use this dt now so after this minus
after four five six
minus
once again i would like to start
another table over here
okay so that it let's go to the next row
so here
after td
we're closing this dr
and starting
another tier
okay
starting another tier after that we talk
about seven eight nine
okay plus
see here talking about seven eight nine
plus here the table is getting close and
it is starting right now like this
see that looks better now
okay but still few more things which i
would like to make it even more
organized but that's not a problem we
will do it later on
okay because you can see 8 is missing
right now
so here
7
we copy this
equal to 8.
eight
yeah that looks better now so now they
are basically completely organized
so the moment i expect my application
so we have a call
dot here then zero then
multiplication
okay so it looks
better now
now i just would like to perform
the overall look and feel
so i need to go ahead and use what css
because without css i really can't
utilize this in a proper way so i have
to start working with the css friend now
in css front how to start first we will
go back to my code and here in my css
we'll start working with font family but
before font fabric i would like to start
with the body part now
body
background color i'm using called d
that looks nice
okay so
i will be using this app.css
in my html to see the look how it is
being appeared right now so in my
index.html file
on the top under my head section
link
style sheet
okay now see it looks better now
going forward
in my css
we want to use
some h1 correct tool so here
we would like to use the h1
texture line
margin top would like to use 50 pixels
this is for h1 let's check
perfect so it is now coming in between
next statement will be called a screen
so we say dot
screen
so in this screen we use the background
color
background color gray
and after that
border sorry
border solid
black and two pixels
after that color
white
font size
medium
next width
we're using this
100
then we talk about cursor
what are the default cursor is
okay then padding
you would like to save 10 pixels
and then
margin
save
auto
then margin bottom
that i'll be using 10 pixels
so in the proper alignment
okay
look
that's how exactly we want that's for a
screen where the exact outcome will be
visible to me
and rest of the details we'll be showing
you one by one and now we'll be talking
about call input
okay
input
type
equal to button
for input type equal to
background color
change to what
right or else i can say
let's walk
okay
and
when the button is active
what i want
let me copy
and put a little button and here i say
active
and this color should be orange red
like this
you can see now how it's basically
looking like it
okay active the color will be like this
okay i'll be talking about color
operators
operator should behave different so i'm
saying dot
operator
in this operator we're saying background
color background color orange
okay then padding
i want five pixels
okay then i want color
that should be black
after this i'm using call border
sorry
the border i'm using this called solid
and then black
after this a bit
i'm using 100
then height
height is 40 pixels
perfect so they shall turn back to what
to your
orange color
and
you can see the moment you take my
cursor on the returns to white
perfect and now those were type number i
also want to change them
so for number
for number i want to say the same option
riding i want 5 pixels
then i need height
of type 40 pixels
then i say color
it looks i want to say called black
then border
border we want solid
black into access for it
black
once again
decimal for decimal i need to have a
different options with me
okay so
let me try to copy this
paste it
does
light blue
padding five pixels color black border
solid
okay black two pixels with hundred
percent height forty pixels five cursor
pointer
perfect
okay looks nice but i have changed the
color to light blue
now
i talk about clear
okay
now come back
and say
clear
okay in this color
background color is changed to light
salmon
light sediment
padding 5 pixels color black
border same width 100
height 40 pixels
fine so cursor
pointer file margin
auto and margin bottom
merging bottom
differences let's check
perfect not looks beautiful
okay
now
here after giving these details we're
talking what called equal part dot equal
so for dot equal also i'm just copying
the same
so we recall
background color adding color
and
after this
since it is a equal so we say padding
five pixels is okay color black fine
border fine with hundred percent height
40 pixels
color and cursor pointers just i don't
need to
it's for dot equal and i want
for container
container
in this container width i want 40
percent
red 40 percent background color white
okay
now here
padding is 15 pixels
so display block
so first of all you call width
you see
display block
which we're taking margin
okay in margin
pixels
okay now align cells
go to
center
okay border radius
border radius let's just say 10 pixels
okay now using box shadow
box shadow 5 pixels
black
and body
so these are details i have it now okay
we have it
background color we are taking it now
align cell
display block border radius
so it's looking beautiful now okay so
this is where exactly my application
works like that
and table when we talk about
everything with
100
okay
that's it
super
so it's now giving me the proper look of
how
my application should be here i can just
see about the container what we have
done
with 40 we are taking background color
let's bring it below
then align
display block
okay margin
okay
and border radius
and uh
fine so i think we're all good now
so
that's it so we'll try and implement
javascript part well everyone so our css
file is ready our html is ready it's
time to just uh
go ahead and talk about my
final question that is called gs part
where i want to basically perform some
calculators
now here i just say function
display
function display which takes
val as in parameter and say
document dot
get element by id
here i'm saying
result
okay dot
value
okay
plus
equal to
whatever we are adding it just basically
try to apply
calculation on the top of that
okay there is a function
after that we have another functions
available here called function solve
here in the solve
we just use the value called let x equal
to
document.id
result
okay
dot
value sorry
dot
value
okay and say connect
y
equal to
perform the calculations for the will be
using one function called
eval
and type
access and parameter
now the next statement will be again
document.
get it
result
dot
value equal
y
okay
now
later on i'll like to use another
function here
function
clear
screen
and here we say
document
like that
so clear screen
song
and
display
three functions are associated with me
and these three functions
are the part of this javascript file
which i'll be calling it
at the end before
the water tank get closed so here
script
equal to
f dot
x that's it okay let's try to execute
now
here
two you can see the values
i will say plus
six
equal to 8 absolutely i say c is clear
the screen
6
divided by
2
equal to 3 awesome so friends your
calculator application is ready
congratulations to all so it is a very
simplest form which we have developed
this is your html which is a template
for you this is the css which is your
complete
the area of like how the look and feel
will look like in of this template
beautification and here last video for
js which is smaller logic but really
meaningful
okay
hello everyone and welcome to the
another very exciting project for our
development in javascript that is known
as call weather pro it is in the
continuation to the series of the
previous project what we have developed
in javascript and this is once again a
very competitive project i'm going to
present to you
which is called weather pro where i
would like to offer you the real-time
weather application into your browser
taken from the real-time weather
applications
okay so let's get started with the new
development of our application which is
called a weatherproof
now once again
compared to the previous project what we
have seen these projects were working
more kind of static in nature where like
you talk about snake game you talk about
tick tock toe or other type of games
like an online quiz
where the data was very much static in
nature but we were presenting the data
in the form of more dynamic in nature
this time
this project we are presenting you while
connecting with the real-time weather
application where i'll be making a one
rest api call or else you can say
asynchronous call and since javascript
is working as a what a pure asynchronous
nature you will be enjoying the way how
the javascript can communicate with your
backend
load the data and represent the records
in a very very beautiful manner
so once again we would need this
vs code editor only just to
develop our code and once again
for developing a presentation part we'll
be using html for
formatting part we'll be using css and
to make some dynamic update we'll be
using javascript now here i'm going to
create a new file name called index
dot html
apparently i just want one more that is
called app.css
and another file we need it
and
that is called
your js file so we're saying
app
dot gs5
so total number of three files are
available to us so i'll start working
with an html now and here
we'll start
with this
html templates
now here first of all i would like to
load my css file which i do not have
right now but certainly i can use it
okay so i can just say link
area
equal to
style sheet
and href
equal to
app dot
css
well that is my css location
now i just want to create
some
this link area i would better use
inside my head tag that will be the more
convenient place
now in my body
i want to have some of the div tags and
there i can decide where the weather to
be displayed so i can just start with my
div diagonal with my div tag i say
class equal to
i can just create a class which later on
i can offer
a different size of or different type of
style so we can say
container
so we're saying dip class equal to
container now within a div tag we like
to use another div tag which is a nested
one
so this step will have another class
called
equal to
app hyphen
title
i have hyphen title
in the same dev tag we can use this a
typical paragraph tag
and here we say weather info
whether
info
now after this paragraph tag
we want to have a text box because i
would expect a client to enter the
detail on which city or for which city
he or she would like to get the details
so we can say input
some properties like id equal to
search
second type
equal to
text
next placeholder
equal to
enter
the city
next
autocomplete i'm saying autocomplete off
the reason because i do not want the
previous value user can see in this case
we can say autocomplete
off i do not want any auto complete in
this
okay
now
here it is getting close now
after that we also want the locations
for that i may use some of the png files
and all but right now i just want to
display the details
of the user
like which city he belongs to and
accordingly i can display the records
right in your application
so for that i really need some of the
div tags once again where i can display
the details
of this particular city so i'm just
having this only text box let me go and
go back and check
how it looks
so i have a call into the city so here
i'll be picking up the city and
somewhere down the line i have to
display
the record so
after this div
we can also have some of the locations
to be displayed
so
we can just use the notifications
and uh also the location where you want
the details to be displayed
okay so we can use div plus
class equal to temperature value
temperature hyphen
value
okay so div plus equal to temperature
hyphen value
inside this i'll be using paragraph tag
and here in my paragraph i'll say iphone
and
this degree centigrade or whatever you
want to display it here
and we'll use
a spandex within this and show
in degree centigrade
that's it
and if you want to define the
temperature description
after this div tag we can use another
day of tag
and inside my tip tag
i can define the temperature description
okay so we can say dip
class equal to
temperature hyphen description
temperature hyphen description
and within this i'll be using what
a paragraph tag
here i'll be displaying
all the description
so right now that is the only thing
which i want let me check
okay so it's here right now
so now let me try to collect the value
from the client
and perform some javascript tag
within this
okay now it's time for us to go back and
try to bring some of the css features
into my code now
now few things i would like to say is i
have basically downloaded some fonts
which i would like to use it in my
application and i also have some of the
icons which i would like to use
during my application presentation so
there are some png files which i have
downloaded from the internet just to
bring more beautiful experience towards
my application development
well this is another background image
which is called widget.jpg which i would
like to
make it as a background of my
existing
application so i'll start with my css
and see how this css can really bring
some new features to my code well
first thing i need to have a call font
face so to make this font face we are
using this statement name called here at
the rate
font phase
and
i like to use font family
font family i'm using
mod select
okay
it is already there with me monster it
and the url
what is looking forward for so we are
saying src
url
and i'm saying under the
font so we have a file called ttf
okay that is called
bolt.ttf that is the file which is there
with me
next thing
so
for every
location i want to use the font family
font iphone
family i want to use same
monster
and the next thing is like in my body
so in my body few details like
background image
i need url
and in this url we can say
bg.jpg
in my background
next thing is background color
that i needed steel blue
then i need height
i'll say 500 pixels
next your background position
this i needed is center
next is your background repeat
i say no repeat
next is your background size
this i'm saying cover
this is my body part
okay let's check
okay
looks awesome now you see this now this
is how
my weather in first looking back in you
can see like the background looks
awesome now now
next thing we required a container
so we are saying
dot
container
container we say width
width 50 percent
next background color
which is using white
next we need it is your ally itself
that will be
center
display
will be block
margin
so in margin we can say 100 pixels
after that border radius
border radius using 10 pixels
and then padding bottom
this padding bottom will be 50 pixels
then box shadow
this box should be giving 5 pixels
10 pixels
20 pixels
and black
this will be with my container so
index.html file we have called container
now
okay looks awesome now
so this is where exactly the details
will be
okay
now
after this css
container we have used
we can talk about called title
you can say
hyphen
title
inside this we will say width
will be 100
then height
will be 150
pixels
then border radius
10 pixels
10 pixels
then we need display
display we need flex
and then we need align items
this align items which is saying center
next we need justify content
that will be the justify content which
is center
then flex direction
would be column
so this option we're using for our tool
name called what
app hyphen
title
okay so here in my index.html file we
have called div class equal to what our
python title equal to weather info let's
check
okay
so
this is another
we have used that is called app title
now we need to use it for paragraph
inside my app title what should be
alignment for my paragraph
so here
this app title
tab title space b
but it should be the class so we are
saying dot
and there also we have to use what dot
because both have to be the class type
okay
so here
you can see now
there is a difference i forgot to add
dot and now you can see it looks better
comparatively
paragraph
so once again in my paragraph i will be
having texture line
center padding
i want 15 pixels
then i need margin
margin would be 0 and
auto
followed by font size
font size
this i'm saying is called 1.2
here
this position then color
we are giving
hash
value
call 333
okay
now here
okay so some changes in a paragraph
well going forward for the search
because if you remember
we have an index.html file we have a
call id code to what
search so here in my
app.css i have to use
hash
search
okay so this search conditions i want to
use it
now inside my search i need few things
one is called display
i need block
after that i need margin left
auto
margin right
quanto
width
i'm looking forward for 5 pixels
height
that i'm looking forward for 20 pixels
then
border radius
i'm looking for four five pixels
then outline
that's called none
let me say border
okay
in this bottle what we can say three
pixels
space solid
okay and once again
see
that's what
let's check
so this is actually the text box
so once again search you use display
block
margin
left auto margin right auto width 5
pixels
width
padding sorry one thing i said
padding should be 5 pixels
width
should be 40
that's why it is smaller but it will be
40
let's check
yeah let's look better now
okay so my text box is now ready i'll be
having some of the details for the
notifications also
so what i need for the notifications
let me go back and create a class for
notification so dot
notification okay
now in notifications i would like to
give some value called background color
and in this background color we are just
giving white
and after that we using display
and we're saying
no
this is for notification and followed by
the notification
we're talking about the same
notification
okay and followed by
its paragraph
we are giving the color first of all we
are saying color
color
is basically red
okay else if you want to give maroon
into the muru
and
after this
the next property we are taking is
called font size
one size we are taking is called 1.2
am
followed by margin
margin we are taking is zero
after that texture line
center
adding 10 pixels
0
so this is for notification p and then
the weather container
okay in my weather container i will say
width
100 percent
sorry
yeah with 100 height
height we're giving 260 pixels
or up to you 250 pixels if you want
background color
this background color we are giving is
called one second white
and followed by margin top
20
pixels
20
pixels this is for weather
container now for the weather icon
weather hyphen
icon
i'm saying width
is 100
and height
128 pixels
just to give in a better look
now the next thing we're using dot
weather
icon icon
space img
here we can display
none
and
sorry display not none i will say
another block
display block and margin
giving zero
space auto
there's four
icon and location icon if i want to give
then
location iphone
could
this location i can i can save with same
width height
so
width i'm giving is 100
then
height i'm giving 40 pixels
and then we give this option called
padding
then take pixels
so it's for location icon
now
followed by location icon we are also
giving call location icon img
okay dot
location hyphen
icon space img
here we're giving the value called
display block
display block width
we're giving is called 32 pixels
and then we're looking forward for
margin
margin would be 10 pixels
and
auto
then cursor
cursor will be pointed for sure
and then we required padding
padding looking forward for 5 pixels
followed by border
border we are looking forward for steel
glue
steel blue
solid
and 2 pixels
then border radius
border
radius
we're looking forward for 10 pixels
and followed by your color
steel
so these are the look and feel we have
to basically offer it for my
current application which i yet to
discuss in my
next development
then i'll be having some small small
properties here
okay
and those properties are nothing but to
give you the details of
like
temperature values so we say dot
temperature hyphen value
okay this temperature hyphen value we
can give it
is 100 percent
and height
we're giving this call 60 pixels
okay this is for temperature value let
me copy this again
and
i'm giving this temperature value space
paragraph
here
i'm gonna give padding
zero
margin
zero
then color
which color you're looking forward for
so we can just say dark grey
okay for any color which you're looking
forward for it's up to you now but if
you want you can change the color also
to another one we're giving this call
hash
293
okay two five one
okay that is a more perfect color for
this
development now font size
4 em
then followed by texture line
and once again center
so this is for
temperature value b
we haven't used much
but you can see now it looks somewhere
in much more better way
okay that is called temperature value p
then you can use a temperature value
span
here
dot
temperature value span
space
span
and here
we'll do the additional dot
now whether this is pan
say color
once again save
and font size
this is for
span
and in the same temperature description
paragraph you can use it
dot
temperature iphone description
description space b
so this will be having the padding
of 8 pixels
then margin
0
followed by color
same color the one which we have used it
earlier
after this color just a texture line
center font size
1.2
this is for temperature description
okay
last which is available for your
location
so let me give the location now dot
location
is space three
here we can say
margin
0
then padding
0
then color
same color i would like to use
after this color texture line
and font size
and copy
text align center and here we'll be
giving some different value equals 0.8
okay and last which is really left with
quality
in that
relative
hair position
i'll be using
absolute
top
from top
i'm using 600 pixels
okay and right
i'm using 120 pixels
that's it
okay so all set
so you can see now
here we have to basically offer the
details how my pictures will be taken
return so this is what my css now will
be applying some of the css into my
applying the css into my html to see how
it really looks like it
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
okay so we have seen some of the css
classes we have introduced
in my html
we have used this uh
autocomplete equal to off then we have
used tip classical temperature
value
okay if you just check carefully we have
used this temperature and there we have
used temperature hyphen
value
but before that we would like to use
some other properties too
okay after this autocomplete equal to
off we want to use
another dev class
okay before my previous div tag is
closed here so here
after this we would like to use another
div tag
div
here in my div
i'll say
class
equal to
location hyphen icon
hyphen
icon
okay and here i'll be using img
src
equal to what under
icons i'm using the file name called
location
dot png
and alt equal to we leave it as it is
the blank
okay
now here the div tag is getting closed
okay
now there's another dev tag is getting
closed here
so two div tags are closed after that
we'll be using another div class for
notification
here class equal to notification
dev class equal to notification and this
step tag is getting close right here
okay now another div for the weather
condition
another div tag and here we say
class equal to weather hyphen condition
whether hyphen what
a condition
or i can say whether iphone container
whichever so i can say
whether hyper container
under this
weather container i like to use
another tip
for weather icon
tip for
class equal to weather hyphen icon
weather hyphen icon
and within this
i want to use another img
src equal to once again
icons
slash unknown
dot png
okay div tag is getting closed
so after this div tag is closed i am
going to use
temperature value
so the temperature value is anyways used
here if you see
raising call temperature value after the
first step tag is closed
you see like temperature value we have
used
after that the paragraph tag
and the temperature hyphen
description b
after the p the div tag is getting close
okay and after this we're using div
class equal to location
so we want to use
div
class equal to
location
and within this location
we want to use one more paragraph tag
[Music]
with this hyphen
after this paragraph it's close
this tip tag this tip tag
and another tip tag three div tags are
closed
that's it
and at the last
before my body tag is closed i would
like to use
script
src equal to
app
dot
js
that's it let's check
great my application looks pretty
beautiful now
so
this i
want to be display only when i don't
find the weather and the location and
also broken field is absolutely
good and now i'll start working on my
javascript front
okay so let's go ahead and start writing
our javascript code
so in this javascript code first of all
i need few things
first thing what i need is call
individual elements or individual
properties of my application i need cost
icon element
i can element equal to
document dot
query selector
and i'll be using the name
call
dot
hyphen
icon
okay
now
copy this
now we will call icon element we can say
location icon
call
location
icon
here we are saying
dot location
hyphen icon
now
next
i need it is called temp element
we are using
the property call dot
temperature hyphen
value
space
p
next we're looking forward for
desc element which is called description
here we're giving temperature hyphen
description
hyphen
temperature has been description space
what
p
then location element
okay we need location element and we use
dot location
space b
next we need notification element
notification element and here we're
going to give the call
modification
notification
so four properties we have taken so we
are selecting all the elements
next
statement what we're going to talk about
see this statement is all about
selecting the elements the next step we
are talking about call
get the input field so we are saying var
input
equal to
document dot
get element by id here we give the name
called
search which is the name or id of my
text box let
city equal to
blank
next we're gonna keep score let latitude
equal to 0.0 we are initializing this
value and let
longitude
let longitude equal to again 0.0 so we
are getting the coordinates right now
so this is how to get the input fields
next we want to apply the events here we
are saying input
the variable dot
add event listener
the variable what we're talking about
which even list will be talking about
key up
key
up
and what even do you want to apply so we
are saying
function
with a parameter name called what
event
and now we would like to attach the
logic now
we send if
what is the condition
event
dot
key code
equal to
13
okay
then
that means number 13 is basically the
enter
see the key code means for 13 13
represent the enter keyword so even dot
key code equal to what 13 so here
say event
dot
preview
default why we're using this because i
do not want my page to be get
refreshed just to avoid this we're using
this and after that we are saying city
equal to
input dot
value
now
you'll be using this another function
because i do not have function created
otherwise i have to call the function
name called get search weather and be
passing this as a parameter so we are
going to get
search
whether i do not have this function i
yet to create this
and pass it here as a what
city
and we say
console
dot log
city whatever we are basically printing
it
okay
so that is the first thing
later on we need to get the data so to
get the data we are just using this
variable name called const
weather
equal to
const weather equal to
curly braces
after that we are saying
weather
dot
temperature
equal to this
and which temperature conditions you
want i'm saying unit
of type what
celsius
i want in a celsius put it in a double
quotes
okay
so next statement will be
getting the details in kelvin i'm saying
cost kelvin
equal to value of the kelvin is what 273
and after that
go on see ultimately what we need is
we need to interact with our backend api
from where i will
get or receive the updated weather
applications
okay
now
to get this i'll be using one very
popular api here that is known as call
openweathermap.org
this is a very very popular app
which
people use it and it's used and trusted
by many companies
clear
so here
what you can do this
open weathermap.org
so you need to basically first of all
get yourself registered because if any
third party application is interacting
it requires that particular
unique
api key
since
as a visitor you really can't get it
unless you register yourself so i have
my api key with me so i'll go here
it'll ask me for the registration
so
i already signed up so if you're not you
need to sign it there's an api key for
me which i need to copy
and this api key i'll be using it in my
project
so i just use this property called const
key equal to
to paste my key here
okay
after this paste in the key but make
sure that you rather using my key you
use your key otherwise this application
sometimes won't work
so i'm basically trying to use this tool
name called geolocation
i'm saying if
geolocation
okay and
navigator
navigator is you know there's a browser
object model element
so here we are using
navigator
okay
navigator dot
geolocation
dot
get current position
in which i'll be passing the first
parameter name convert
set position
and second parameter will be show error
in case
if any error is received
okay
else
in the sales condition what would happen
i'm using this statement name call
notification
element
you see this notification element dot
style
dot
notification remain dot
get elements by class name
but i don't need this rather i will use
what the style
dot display equal to
block
then i will be using the same
notification element dot
inner html
equal to
you're gonna use a paragraph
saying what browser
doesn't
support
so you have to enable the current
location of use
okay that's where exactly
so after that we have to basically set
what the user position
okay if the user is having that support
available
so after this
location we'll be just using another
function here
function
set
position
it will i'll be taking
position as a parameter
and take latitude
latitude equal to
position dot
chords chords for coordinate star
latitude
okay like that
longitude
equal to
what position dot
quads
dot
longitude after this we'll be using this
function called what
get
weather so this get weather will be the
function in which you will be passing it
so this function will be soon seen
i'll be having it defined below but as
of now we are just saying
get weather and in which this we are
passing
latitude and
longitude
that's it
so we have this function name called
what
set
position
in which will be passing all the values
okay at the same time
i'll be using one more function here
that is called function
not function in fact
i would like to use location
icon the one which you define at the top
dot
add event listener which even listener
i'm saying
one click
second
function
which take
event doesn't parameter
and inside this i'm saying console just
to confirm whether the records have been
taken console.log
hey
just
and
we say get weather
okay once again we'll be passing what
latitude and longitude same i just copy
this
and paste it here
okay everyone so we have written till
here when i try to run my browser
so i should see there is a message name
called show error is not defined
but obvious because this message what
we're writing it here is called show
error
okay this
as a function as a parameter it is not
defined let me define this function
called show error so we are saying
function
show error which take
error as in sorry just take
error is in parameter
now in this we are using
notification
dot
style
dot display
equal to what
block
after that once again
notification element
dot
inner html equal to what
we're just using this as a paragraph
and here
error
dot
message
okay and after that
paragraph
so this is how we are basically writing
it down
and now
see it is immediately asking you
to know your location okay if i say
allow
that's okay
okay so nothing
you can see now it is saying get weather
is not defined because right now the
moment i click on this
so it is saying like get weather is not
defined but obvious because i told you
this get weather function i need to
develop so i get to develop this
function called get weather but before
that i'm using another function called
function
get search weather
get
search weather in which i'll be passing
what
city name
now
what exactly my apa will be in case if i
want to make a call i will be using let
api equal to
now the url will be what
http
colon double forward slash api dot
open
weather map dot
org now open weather map dot org
slash
data
slash two point
sorry two point
five that is a version slash
weather
okay question mark
i have to take the city dynamically so
i'm saying weather
question mark q
equal to
here
we're using what city
and
we're using amp percent
app id
equal to the one app id we have used it
already
okay what is that
that key
so that is the key
which you've already written so that i
might if you're passing it right over
here
okay q equal to city and applied equal
to this
now after that to make the restful api
call i'll be using one independent or
by default api which is available to us
that is called what
fetch
okay so if you just check this fetch it
is basically a take requestion form
and give you the what a promise response
so return type will be the promise type
in this fetch i'll be passing what
the
api and we'll be using dot
then that means if the request
is successful using function
function
response
then function as a parameter response we
are saying let
data equal to
response dot i'm expecting the response
of type of what json
is in json and return what
data
so it will be returning data back to me
now if it is successful then what then
i'm saying dot then once again it is
chaining
again
function
again
data's in parameters
now in this case we'll be getting lot of
things
i'm saying
whether
okay dot
temperature it's a predefined dot
value
equal to i'm using what
math
dot
floor inside this we are passing what
data dot
main
dot temp it is a predefined property we
are receiving it now
hyphen
kelvin what are the kelvin values
basically we're taking score 273 on the
top
minus
kelvin
followed by
another property what
weather
dot description
weather dot
description
equal to we're using
data dot
weather
zeroth position because it contains a
lot of data but i will be taking what
description out of that
then
weather dot
icon
id
whether dot icon id equal to
data
dot
weather
dot
icon then
dot icon then once again
weather dot
city
okay equal to
data dot
after this
weather dot country
dot
equal to
data dot
sys dot
so these are the properties i have it
right now with me
okay and once i received all the
property i'll be using dot
then
i'll be using one function
and i will say what
display there is no function written
called display weather but i'm gonna say
there's a one function name called
display
weather
this function i had to write
but this function just putting it here
okay
now this is closed
after that
since i need to get a weather from the
api provider
so i have to also pass what the latitude
and longitude which i am receiving it
from the client because
here i just want to have two things
the properties as well as whether both
and both i'll be using it one by one
okay so here
we have kept this gate search weather
and now i'll be calling one more
function
after this logic and i'm giving the name
called function
getweather
okay it takes two parameter one is
called what latitude
and thing is called
longitude so we have two things called
latitude and longitude
and here i'm using this property called
what let
api equal to
once again
if you remember
i have used this statement i'll just
copy the same
and
pass it it
here but challenge would be this time
i will not be passing city name because
the two options are available either you
type the city name or else you click on
the icon and let your application
identify the location which you belong
to
so after this feather question mark
here i will not be using q i'm using
what
led
equal to
latitude
okay
and we're using
and
hello in
equal to
we're using logitude
okay and app id equal to what key so
this is the variable which we have it
now
okay
now
similar thing which we have used it on
the top okay called fetch api
so i just copy this same fetch api again
because i really don't want to waste
time on keep on typing the code
when we know it very well it can be
similarly done i just copy and
paste it here so the same fetch api
dot then response data equal response
dot json return data then
whether that temperature method flow
says country dot display weather so we
have used the same thing here and after
that we have to use the last function
here that is called display weather
display
weather
and here in my display whether i can use
what
i can element dot
inner html equal to
i'll be using
img
src
equal to
icons
slash
dollar
and we'll be passing what whether
okay dot
icon id
okay
dot
png
okay so
that we are basically putting it here
dot png and after that
it is closing that
okay and this icon we also need to close
here
so rather than closing this i'll be
closing that and
this i'll be closing it here
now
we'll be using top element
sorry temp element
template
dot
inner html
equal to what
we'll be using this dollar
weather dot
temperature
dot
value
okay
and
after this value we can just use
this asterisk sign
the one which i told you
okay and use
span
span
okay next we are using call talk element
so we have that sorry dsc element
we have got dec element dot
inner html equal to
weather dot
description
and last but not least location
element dot
inner html
equal to
what
i'll be using once again this
and here
weather dot
city
comma
dollar
weather
dot that's it
these two properties we have to use it
and we're all done
let's check with my code
if i get any error
now
allow
so
awesome you can see now
27 broken clouds globe undefined that's
perfectly fine intercity
you can see awesome beautifully it is
showing you the conditions it's saying
smoke 28 degree centigrade and now let
me put another city here i'm gonna say
called cool
awesome your application is working
perfectly fine
and
let's see one more
i would say
awesome if getting your learning started
is half the battle what if you could do
that for free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
and now we are planning to develop one
very special game for you
in javascript and now it's time to talk
about another very interesting game that
is known for tic tac
tic tac toe is
world's favorite game we have already
played a lot in our childhood days and
still my favorite game
so i have decided to basically offer you
this tic-tac-toe game developed in
javascript html plus css which can
create something really very great
effects for the end users so let's go
and start developing our next game
that's called tic tac toe
so in this tech tactile i will start
working with creating a folder called
tic tac and inside this i'm going to
create a new
file name called index
dot html
now here onwards the same thing
i'll be creating this html tags
and now here onwards
we want our some classes for headers and
footer
but so we're going to create some div
diagram
so in this div tag
i'll be creating some of the tags
in which the thesis class will be
applied so we just gonna create a
classes
uh sorry i'm gonna just use those
classes but we'll create it later on so
just go ahead and create those so we are
saying div
okay so now this point onwards is my
first dev tag inside this i'll keep
my h1 tag
and under this h1 i will be offering
some of the headings which will be
useful
to contain some necessary information
with regards to this game so tim here we
say
h1
and uh inside this h1 we give the
message called class
equal to header
and here i'll give the name call
is a tic-tac-toe game
after this div class
yeah here we will start working with our
form tag
within my form tag i will start my div
after div tag i will use
label
so label for player 1
or else i can say player 1 and inside
this let's give the name call layer
label is closed
and
after this label will start working with
our input tag
input
now in this input what are the details i
need first i need call type equal to
text number one second
placeholder equal to enter name
next name
equal to player one
next we want id
equal to
player one
and then
any class if i want to apply
anyways we're gonna close this this is
my first text box
and
same thing i would like to create for my
another one
so the first div tag we have used let me
go and create another tip tag
in this div tag i'll use the same label
copy the same
paste it here and this is for player 2.
so we have this
two players with me and after this div
tag
i'll offer the submit button now
input typically submit
start game
now the form tag is closed here
dev tag is also closed
so
you want the div tag to be closed or
before that it's up to you now
so here we have a called div class
whichever we have taken so if you want
you can basically put it later or before
whatever
so we will basically form that with this
so form tag is there later on you can
just show
some containers where the details will
be visible to me
so here after the form tag
let me try to offer but first check
whether it is really working fine
so here
yeah we have this option called enter
name in the name after the stick tag
tool
so
yeah
so here the details we have taken input
text and input typically text
okay so two values we are taking now and
accordingly we will go ahead now finally
after the form tag
we would like to start with working with
the tape tag again
div and inside this div
i since i haven't created any css
classes so those we can use it little
later on but let's have
this div
and inside this tip i would like to use
remote tip tag
okay and here we want to use one more
div tag
so inside this div we will be using one
more div tag
so
in this div we can just give the value
called data id equal to zero
id equal to
zero it's just the value
we are passing it
div
data equal to zero the div tag is
getting closed
fine so
that's how we want it now
so here
the first div tag is closed like that we
can create another data id so 0 1 2
total number of 3 we want to create it
so i want to create 0 1 2 3 4 5 like
this
so the way we have created here
for this div let's go and create one
more div tag
id equal to
one
two
three options we have it now
okay like that i can keep on creating
the others also
two
three
four
five so zero one two three four five dot
number of five we have created
one more i would like to create it now
here for six
there'll be no difference because we
haven't changed anything here
okay
so the div tag is getting closed here
okay
and
that's it
and if you want to create a some clear
mode or button that you can basically
offer it little later on
but here
we can use one more div
and here we say dew
the classical relative
and within this step tag i can use
any image tag if i want
so i just leave it as it is
and after this
i can create one more tip tag
and insert this another tip
okay
and
under this i'm gonna create
a button
okay and in this button
we'll be having some value
okay
we can secure the value name called
replay
this button is created and now we can
create a clear board
spam
and here is a clear board
that's it
okay so here
it's just
a small game i want to develop it
better
now there's no user interface has been
used so this user interface will be
using it later on by offering them a
pure
look and feel so that you know it gives
me
more better look when your application
will start
but most importantly i need to start
working with a javascript part where the
logic will get calculated here
okay so
we want to start with the javascript so
let's get included the javascript with
my code
so here
i can see here script tag
script
equal to
now the file i haven't created so let it
be as it is
that's it so this is my script tag and
let me try to include my
style cheat answer so
i just say
link
real quick style sheet
into the name called
css though i haven't created what i'm
giving it okay
that's it
so we have taken
this html into our
consideration now we'll be creating this
css as well as the javascript to make
this example complete
well we are ready with our html but it's
time to basically go back and spend time
on our javascript we're going to create
a new file now with the name called
app.js
and inside this we will start
writing the logic with our main
application
okay
now the first thing is how we're going
to start now
yeah
so
first thing what we need to do is we
need to attach window
dot
add event listener
and when the window will load some logic
should happen so i'm saying load
second is the name of the function
so the name of the function perhaps does
not exist but i can give the name called
app
which i'm going to create it shortly
now here first of all let me try to
create a game board i'm saying let
gameboard
equal to now let me have some of the
values because it is
eight digit
so we just make it
like that
and one more
for making the time
okay
so that's how
we're going to create it now
okay
now this is all empty right now
after that we're going to create let
turn
just a new variable
equal to
zero
what this is it keep tracking if x or
zero player its turn
like which player turns it to b so just
it is trying to mention it i'm saying
let
villar equal to
false
okay now let's go and create the player
so
create
layer how are you going to create a
player we say const
player equal to
what we're gonna pass
name
okay equal to
now inside this we can say name equal to
name
next we say return
name
that's it
okay after that i'm defining let
here
x equal to
player
with the empty value
and again
player
y
equal to
there is an empty value now let's try to
initialize the app
okay
initialize
now inside this initializer app we're
going to create a new function
function
app
and inside this we're going to create a
variable likewise saying let
input feed
equal to first of all
document dot
get element by id here
we're gonna take
the
class name of this particular
text field so we are saying input
hyphen
field okay
dot
focus
okay now after this we have to say const
add players
equal to once again
document
dot
get eleven by id let me just give the
name called player form
okay
next we are saying
add
player
okay dot
add event listener we want to attach the
event
on which event
submit event
and what logic
add
players
okay
after that once the players are added we
are saying
let replay
replay button equal to once again
document
sorry
document dot
get a remain by id or rather i will say
document.queryselector
document. query selector
replay type
btm
okay
just the name we are basically taking
that and here we say
sorry
replay button
dot
add event listener
which even i want to say
click
ok that is the first event second
reset board
reset
board
that will basically pass in that
okay
now
this is the initial case which we have
it
now beyond that i will add
this is the layers what we have added
and right nut slides to add the players
so this is how we have initialized after
that let's
add
please
how to basically add the players here we
have to just define the function
add
players okay so take
event as a parameter
and say event
dot
prevent
prevent default this present default
will try to prevent
the default
uh you know
behavior which is submitting to we get
avoided and now here we say
if this
dot
player
one so we just define the property
called player one
if this dot player one dot what
value
okay
is
blank
okay or
this dot
player 2
sorry
let's start
player 2
now i just want to find it out its value
also
value
black
then what i should do
in this case i am saying alert
you
almost
enter
name
for
each
field
the user has to add the values and after
that
return
okay
now the next thing is like we would like
to select the players in this insight is
by saying cost
player
form
container
again
const play from controller container
equal to
document dot
query selector
document query selector here we will
just pass
the value call
enter
icon okay now we say cost
board main equal to
document
dot once again
query selector
for
underscore main
okay after that
player
form container
dot
class list
dot class list dot
add here we're giving the name forward
height container
all right
container
and after that you just say board mail
board main
dot class list
dot
remove
height
hyphen
this dot
player 1
dot
value
ok this for player x copy this
player y
2
and after that
that's it so we have done it now
so
we'll be calling other functions one by
one but that is the first thing which
we've implemented
well so
add player function is added right now
and after this add player we have to
basically call
one more that is called which returns
the current player something return
current player
and here what i will do is we'll just
write function
and here we say
current
player and in this current player what
we will do is
we will say return
turn
just variable
okay percentile
2 we're just adding it with this
zero
okay if it is
then
x
turn i'm telling you
okay or else
so we're adding like the current player
who says the current tail right now
well
after this adding the return current
player we're gonna add another function
that is known as call return the current
player return current player is having
this value and after that we need to say
resize the square in event browser is
resized
once again if the browser is getting
resized automatically the square size of
your
tic-tac-toe should also get increased so
we just say
resize
squares
and here we gonna say this option equal
window
dot
add
event listener
now we have a call option called resize
here
and the second parameter what we are
parsing is called on
resize
okay on resize
now let's try to add it
after this we are writing this function
called
function
on
resize that is a function name for me
the one which we are passing into the
second parameter
we are saying let
all cells
equal to
document
dot
query selector or
in this we are passing
board
underscore
cell
okay and then we are using another
option called what let
cell height
equal to
all cells
with the position
okay dot
of
set
width or
set width
after that we are saying all cells
dot
for each
here we are passing
[Music]
and after that we are using cell
dot
style
dot
height
equal to now he'll be using this
backtick and use this
dollar sign
and say
cell
height
and then to in a pixel
so this will be taking the dynamic
values
okay that's it that's it over
now we have to just launch our build
board
now
billboard
build
board so how we gonna build our board
now for this we are saying function
billboard
and inside this billboard we will see
this option called let
reset
container equal to
document dot
once again query selected
and pass the value call dot reset
okay and after that we are saying
reset container dot
class list
dot remove
and we are passing the value call
reset hyphen
hidden
this value and after that
we may call some other type of functions
also
okay so for those functions i can say
first will be called on
resize
after that we are calling
add
self click listener
but i do not have that function with me
these functions we need to create it by
your own
okay so we will just leave those for a
time being let's go back and create
another functions now so we just want to
write another event with self click
event for play to attempt
to make move so here we try to say
cell
click
event
for
player 2.
attempt
to
make
move
now this function need to create it so
we just say function now
we just say function
and give the name of the function
to make move now
function
make
move
it takes
give it as a parameter
and here we are saying console.log
and say
now let's go back and try to check
another condition that is called let
current cell
equal to
percent because you have to read the
value from there and here we are saying
what
event dot
current target
sorry
even dot
current target dot
first element child
okay dot
data set
dot
id
so we're reading these values
after that we use another variable
called let
sell to
add
token
now here we are typing document
dot
query selected
and here
you know using backtick
i'm using this file you call
data hyphen id
okay equal to
here we are using
once again in a single quotes
dollar
current cell
okay so this value we are taking it like
that
after that we are using this situation
called if
cell
to add token dot
inner html
exterminatory mark
blank
once again if cell to add
token dot inner html
equal to blank
then what next
so cell to add token
dot inner html
equal to blank then what you should do
i'm saying console
dot
log
and give the value the one which you
want
okay
so in this console.log what value we can
give it
cell to add token
we have it it is taking this value to
the current cell dot inner html
console.log
and inside my console.log we can set
this
cell is
already
taken
so values are already taken for this and
now we will be
returning those values
after that we will be using else
condition
and here we use once again if
current player
okay
is x
then we'll be using this option called
cell
see we have this property option
available called send to add to consider
using cell to add token
okay dot
text content
equal to
current
player okay and we say
game mode
the one which you have created pass in
this game mode
this value call
current cell
and in this correct cell value will be
equal to
x
okay
else
we can say
send
to add token dot
text content
equal to
current player
okay and say
game board
current cell
equal to
like this
okay so here we are adding the values
like that
so it is closed after that we can just
use the function name for
is winner to check whether the user is
winner or not so we are saying
is
winner
okay and
after that we are saying
turn
plus plus
after that we are saying
change
we do not have the function name called
change board header names
okay so it's just like that we're giving
it so as usual we can leave this
function for a time being
and we'll call this little later on so
leave it as a for the time being
okay so your function is now ready
so the next thing what we need to check
whether
it is tie or not okay so we are saying
function
check
if
i
we're just checking the function
whether it is tie or not so here we say
if
the condition is turn
greater than 7
alert
again
okay we can say give over first we can
say our type
okay
well after that we are saying winner
function
is winner
now what we will check is we'll check
const
winning sequences
winning sequences
and here
sorry
here
we are having this array and having the
different conditions associated we say 0
1
2 probability we are checking it
and then i just copy it
well placing 0 1 2 and here is saying
eight
and zero three six again
zero
three
six
and once again one four seven
four
seven
and next we have a call two five eight
eight
then we are checking the vertical zero
for it
so these conditions we are adding it now
after this array we can say
varying sequences start
for each
and give the name call winning compose
and inside this varying compound we are
giving let
cell one equal to
varying combos position 0
then
that copy
and paste 3 times
cell
2 cell 3
and here we get the value called what
one
is true
three values are giving it and after
that
we are checking the condition
let's say
if
and here the conditions you're checking
what exactly that would be for the game
board you're saying
game board
set
one
current player
sorry
current player
ampersand time percent
come down
game board
cell 2
i just want to copy this the same line
and paste it multiple times
now here
we are checking the condition for cell 2
and cell 3
and
cell 3
and
after that
we're starting the position
so after that
we're starting the position call
[Music]
by cutting this condition called
consensed
query selector
all
and here let's select the position dot
board
and discard
cell
okay
then after that we will be using
cells
dot
for each
cell
and inside is what we are passing they
are saying
let
cell id equal to
cell dot
first
element child
okay
dot data set
dot
id
so this is the value which you are
basically adding it now and we're using
one more if condition
we're saying if
cell id
now we're talking about call cell id
triple equal to
cell 1
or
saline
cell 2
or
salary equal to
cell 3
okay and in that case we can use
cell dot
class list
dot
just give the class name
winner
so here we'll be giving the winner and a
part of that we can use the other
conditions too
okay so here it is
adding the value and now let's say
let
layer equal to
document dot
get element by id
so you can basically define it so
current player you want so we can use
the current layer or whichever
conditions you want so here we use what
the cell winner
now
small change rather than using correct
player we can use
the current
player text
the new variable we are creating it
current player text document dot rather
than saying get element by id
we can say
query selector
and in this query selector will be given
the value
by saying dot board
the value which we are giving it here
and that query selector
value whichever you given this let me
try to put it in a
parenthesis
like this
okay now here we just checked
if current player
x
then what
then in this case we can say
current player what is the value we are
using current text
dot
inner html
equal to
now we can define the value whichever
you want to
operate
we just use a condition called div
class equal to
okay so we are saying congratulations
okay and here you say
congratulations
along with
and here the dip tag is getting closed
like this
okay
so that's the message we are basically
printing it
and after that
we give this value
and say this message called
winner equal to
and after that
if you want to apply
remove
that function we haven't written we'll
be talking about a little later on and
just say return proof
so your function is ready now
and later on we can just check the
condition if filler
if
winner
or you can say
check
if type
and
return false
that's it
now in our continuation to this example
we're gonna develop another function
which
the name is called change board header
names so let's continue by defining the
new function called function change
board
header names
so this change board header names will
be the new function for us and here we
would like to check whether the user is
winner or not so here we say if
not
winner
then what
then in that case we have to say let
current player text
equal to
document
dot
query selector in this will be getting
the details like dot
board
and here we gonna give the name called
player
and hyphen turn
player hyphen turn
now later on after this particular
variable we have to just check the
condition by saying if
current player
equal to x if the position is x sorry
let me try to put in a capital letter
here
x
then we will say
current player
dot
inner html equal to
now here we have to just use the same
option called backtext because i want to
go multilines that's the benefit of this
backtick and here we say in our inner
html span
class
equal to
name
hyphen hyphen
style
close this and here we want to use
the statement
now this
value
we want to write it with name attribute
so it is getting close and here we are
saying dollar
with this player
x
dot
name
and then
close the
span tag
and we
say you are
up
like this
and after that
we say dev
class equal to
we're just going to create a class which
later on we can apply the css style on
the top of that u hyphen r
hyphen
winner
and here we say closing the div tag
so dip tag is closed that's it and now
after this line
what next we have this called else
condition
else
what else here we say
current layer
text
dot inner html
inner html equal to
after this
we gonna write the span
class equal to here we say name
hyphen hyphen same option we're gonna
use it
so in this condition so
winner conditions so let me try to copy
the same rather than copying it again
and again
i'll just copy the whole text
expand class equal to name hyphen knife
and style
player rather than saying x you need to
use file you are up you are
winner
okay so here it's getting closed
well after this what we need to do
create another function called reset
port
function
reset board
now in this function reset board we just
say console.log
a small message resetting
resetting is added now afterwards we
will be using
the game board
and the same game board what we have
used earlier
i'll be using the same conditions
on the top
if you remember
that was the game code for me so i'll be
using the same keyboard
to copy this
yeah with the same condition
okay give me equal to this
after that line we will say let
cell to add token
sell to add token equal to
document
dot query selector all
here
in this i'll be using
another class called
later
now
cell to add token
whichever we've used dot
for each
square
and within this square we would like to
use square
dot
text content
equal to
black
after that
square
dot
parent element
dot
class list
dot
remove and here we would like to say
board
okay underscore underscore
cell
winner so these classes we had to create
because these css classes were just
using this but we haven't created
we'll be using it later on
so that was the point
now after that we are defining the turn
value
turn
equal to zero because we are resetting
it and
winner equal to
false
after that winner equal to false we just
define another variable called define it
current player text
current player text equal to
document
dot
query selector all
yeah document query select all
so here
we're gonna use the name called board
define player hyphen hyphen turn
after that current player
current layer
text
currently text dot
inner html equal to once again we have
to use the condition for
up
and winner point
so let me try to copy this
inner html equal to
okay and in this we have to say player x
dot name
okay just everything is same no change
at all
okay now
here after that we're gonna write one
more function called function
add
cell
click
listener that means when i will be
adding
or clicking something to my cell
what kind of event i would like to
listen
here
we are saying const
cells equal to
document
dot
query selector all
let's check
the condition board
board
cell
and here once again we say sell stock
for each
dot
for each
and here this is cell
dot
add
event listener
which event i want to listen
click and the second parameter will be
handler
once call
make move
okay and this function which we have
created called add cell clicks listener
okay this i'll be calling it here
perfect
later on once it is done let's try to
add one more function called function
remove
cell
click
listener
remove cell
click listener
now here we say
let
all
cells
equal to
document
dot
query selector all
let's pass
board
cell
and now we say
all cells
dot
for each
cell
and here we say cell dot
remove
event listener
which event
click
and second parameter will be
make
that's it so friends now here
most of our javascript code is written
now
so going forward we would like to use
css
and finally we'll be applying everything
into our html file
well after the javascript file is ready
towards my application now it's time to
go and create
our html file now sorry the css
so
inside my tic tac i have got app.js and
index.html ready now here i'm going to
create another file here called
app.css see you can basically put this
app.css in either folder like in static
folder but i have just kept it outside
now from this point onwards i would like
to start with my basic functionalities
okay what those are let's start with the
first feature called modding
with my body
some basic settings i would like to do
like in background image background
color so i just start with
background color
background color i can just use it as a
white
okay
but i don't think so it's really needed
it so if you want you can have it
otherwise leave this background because
it's by default gonna be white only
and now
next would be called height
height will be 800 pixels
next background position
background position i just say like
center
next background repeat in case if you do
not want to repeat the image
background repeat
and here i say no repeat
next background size
here we are saying cover
okay so it resize the background image
to cover the entire container
okay so that's what the body part
now the next thing is we have to select
the
rest of the css classes so first select
div
dot relative
inside this dot relative is first say
call position
position we are saying absolute
next is stop
from the top i'm just making 760 pixels
next right
right is saying 120 pixels
next
after this we are saying height
container
height dot
container or sorry hide hyphen container
here in height hyphen container we will
display
display colon
none
well after that we have to use the
header point
header inside the cellar we will say
color
will be by default white but still we
just say color
and
white
next text line
we just say center
next margin
margin will be 50 pixels
next font family
font family i am selecting called
permanent marker
permanent
permanent marker
okay next class we are talking about
call interplayer that's called dot
enter hyphen
players
now in inter hyphen players we will say
color
will once again
we can use any other player but we can
just use white or any color you want or
you can just use
hash
okay
margin
margin we are giving it's called zero
auto width
we're looking forward for eighty percent
next texture line
center
position
relative
now
next we're going forward for input field
in this input field we just say border
border two pixels
solid
and black
next
outline
outline none
i do not want any outline to be there
next padding
i can take 4 pixels
8 pixels
4 pixels 8 pixels now margin
we are saying zero
zero ten pixels
okay and finally
for pixels
after sparging we say font size
18 pixels
okay so that is your input field
next we are talking about something
called input field focus
input
hyphen field
okay colon
focus
now here
border
two pixel
solid
right
or any other color which you want to use
it
next
how you want your submit button to be so
i'm saying
dot
submit hyphen btn
border
2 pixels
solid
and black
adding
8 pixels
and again 8 pixels
font size
80 pixels
now with
250 pixels
followed by border radius
5 pixels
next your margin from top
let's take 10 pixels
after that background color
let's take
white only
okay
so this is the property
now going forward you can associate
with your submit button active and
submit button focus so we are saying dot
submit
hyphen
btn
colon
active
and
two options we are taking
followed by condition outline now
[Music]
next border
we're talking about two pixels
solid
and the color
red
okay
so that's the one
and after that we like to use over
dot
submit hyphen button colon
over
what you want
change the background color
to what
white
you can use white smoke
well
here we like to use
a
dot
board
here we'd like to use player
hyphen
so these are the classes we were using
in our javascript we remember
and here we say color
color we're using once again
white or you can use this white smoke
whichever you want
so
well later on
texture line
center margin
10 pixels
0
and 10 pixels
height
54 pixels
okay
so these are the properties initially we
have taken
okay so after this
turn let's go and start another classes
here i'm saying dot
name hyphen hyphen
style
and here we are saying color
red
and then font size
22 pixels
well
now coming back to the another
properties now we're talking about the
next important called border container
called board container dot
bot container here we define width
which is 40 pixels we are taking
or sorry 40 percent we can rather take
after that background colors
that we can say coded blue
okay
next margin
we're taking is 0
and
auto
after that font size
font size we are taking 0
next border
bottle we are taking 2 pixels
then solid
and then black
followed by
box shadow
if you remember this box shed is one of
the very very season
three popular property here we're
defining three pixels
three pixels
three pixels
zero pixels
and
rgb
we can talk about called black
okay
so my
border color will be shading color will
be
black
after that we're offering this
board cell
dot
now in this board cell we are defining
width
now in this width we are using
calculation
ca lc and in this calculation we are
defining hundred percent
okay divided by
three
this calculation
after this
the next property will be display
display will be inline block
next font size
we're taking 40 pixels
well texture line
center border
we are taking
two pixels
solid
and
black
adding 20 pixels
vertical align
top
next font family
this formula can use permanent
permanent markers
okay
now
next option
a part of this
we have a call
your board circle
board
cell iphone
winner
i would say rather icon
[Music]
let's make background color
red
okay
and
[Music]
later on just use
letter
now in this letter we just give the
color combination so color will be
white
next position
relative
top
50
next transform
translate by
to minus 50
after that font family
we are making it once again permanent
marker
let me copy
okay
now
here next option will be called winner
container
here we're giving
winner
with dot
dot
winner hyphen
container
okay so for this winner container what
are the values we want to use it
that's you want to basically do it so
for this with a container what i would
rather suggest is you can use dot
reset
text align
center
margin
20 pixels
that is for reset and now reset hidden
inside this reset heading we will set
display none
display
none
okay after this the replay button
it's yeah now you could talk about
replay button dot
replay hyphen
vta
and here width
we make it
to
25
okay
and followed by padding
10 pixels we take it from here
and 20 pixels
border
this bottle we are taking is called 2
pixels
by solid
okay and black color
now later on
border radius
border radius we're taking 5 pixels
later on outline
i'm saying none
after this outline we say letter spacing
now this letter spacing would be again
0.
after that
text transform
this text track form value we are
talking about call
uppercase
next font size
font size
we're taking 16 pixels
then margin top
margin top would be 12 pixels
then word spacing
that you are taking three pixels
followed by background color
this you are taking white as usual
this is for your replay button
okay
now in a similar line we can also have
call dot
replay iphone
btn colon hover
followed by dot
replay hyphen
active
now apply the common style outline
we are making it null
then color
we are making is called white
then background color
will be black
okay
and
when it comes to the congratulations
so we'll be using this
dot
okay
so this congratulations
class will be using font size
to what 24 pixels
and after this we are using this call
winner dot u
hyphen r
dot
winner
in this winner we will be taking
font size
okay that's 18 pixels
after that height
we are taking 18 pixels again
then line height
line height we are taking 18 pixels
and
then
margin two pixels
and then zero
okay that's it so
last but not least we would like to use
this
dot
replay
hyphen btn
this i am saying with 50 percent
so this is what my css file is all set
i know it was pretty lengthy but it is
required for this particular application
okay everyone so we are all ready with
our css also now it's time to go back to
our index.html file
and take care about the final finishing
touch
so we have this index.html file with us
and now
the css class which we were using it in
our application that is known as call
this
permanent marker this class is not by
default available so we have to include
this
using this external api
so here
where we have a call css with us
before that
we want
link
so within this link we want a one
variable name called href
equal to now we have to give the proper
location by saying https
colon double forward slash fonts
dot google apis
okay dot com
slash
css
question mark
family
equal to
permanent
plus
marker
okay so if you just copy this
into your browser
you will get to know
where exactly it is using
okay if i just copy and paste it
so i just need to say https before
yeah https
fonts
dot
google apis
dot com
slash oh spelling wrong
css family equal to permanent marker
that is the main url
from where i can take this kind of font
so here
css so that's what i was cross verifying
it
well it's there we have included our css
also but in which class we need to use
that is an important now
js i also want to include it
so here
in my head tag only
i would like to include
script
src equal to
app.js
so here my script is actually loaded now
after that
if i just go back and check
the
final outcome of my code
which is
index.html file
well it pretty much look like in basic
nothing else has started when we talk
about call start game
okay so it needs to start because there
is no css class are attached so i need
to attach those classes within my code
so here onwards we have to start with
offering those css classes so that at
least i can apply
those common behaviors to my application
okay like here we have a call
div
we haven't attached any class to this
after this body we have a part tip h1
class equal to header
tic tac toe then we have a call div we
have a call
body
uh
under this we have a call another div
tag so just imagine how many type of
classes are available when we have
called tip class equal to header
div class is closed again we have a
called one more div tag so like that
multiple css files are there where we
have to apply the new css class
to make it happen so now we have to just
go back and change our html and to apply
our main class
so this is what my final html which
looks like the same you can see we have
added
all those type of css classes which we
had that is called inter player
player form player container label
placeholder and player container and if
you see all different type of classes we
have attached this to
okay because
here only my css class will get applied
and the javascript will apply those kind
of dynamic css based on certain
conditions so these css classes are
already there added inside your html
page
our app.css is ready
app.js is also ready now let's go back
and try to reveal how it looks like
awesome so it looks like pretty nice
tic-tac-toe is a game it is expecting
when i say start game it says you must
enter a name for each field validation
is working
let me try to add
two names and say start game awesome so
now you can see it is saying hey you are
up
now let me try to give the values
awesome now you can see
it's saying like hey you are a winner
great so guys congratulations on this
the first example of how the tic tac
door game is used so it is a classical
example of css
javascript and html together
so this time we're going to talk about
our next very interesting feature that
is called dealing with another example
that is called snake game so sting keep
is one of the very very powerful
example which i'm going to share with
you which will help you to understand
like how
we offer a very simplest way of
developing a mini project
okay that is something which is a snake
game let's see how the snake game is
important and how we're going to deal
with this
these are our previous examples which we
have seen which i will call a project
which we have created that is called
quiz application and now we're going to
start working with our new project
now here first of all i'm going to
create a new folder
that is called snake
again
and inside the system we need some new
folders
uh first folder i'm going to create it
inside this that is called images
and
within this snake games i'm going to
create few new files that is called
index
dot html
and here
i'm going to create a new file name
called app
dot
js
at the same time i'll be having some of
the css files if i need so i can say
app dot
css so total number of three files i
have it now let me close down all the
files whichever i have opened it earlier
so
now that looks cleaner approach
so
this is the snake game for us from where
we need to start
and we have an index.html file and here
i will i think we should create
our basic html syntax
and
here i would like to include
our script tag
script
src equal to
app.js
that's it and now going forward we will
start developing
our next
implementation of
snaking
now inside my body tag i would like to
have some
basic property called speed
okay and later on i'll be taking the
input from the client so we're saying
input type equal to
so here we can justify the speed and we
can give id
equal to
gamespeed
and followed by
value
equal to we can give the value called 5
initial value
and min
equal to
1 that is the minimum value
and max equal to
9 that is the maximum and minimum value
we can offer beyond that i won't allow
the users to go
and step
that means the increment value that is
one
well that is the input type and now
another input we are taking input
type equal to
button
and
value
equal to
start
and then id equal to
game start
okay so we're giving these values
after that
i can give some
bricks
so two bricks we are giving it and start
working with the div diagonal
and in this div tag i'll be using the
canvas
it is a html5 feature
we use canvas
and i just give id equal to
game
area
there is a canvas
and
after this canvas
we will
that tip tag is closed here after the
dev tag i can use another tab tag
there
here i can say
class equal to
i may not have any class written but i
can say
class equal to related so later on if i
want to apply any css style
i can certainly apply
and after that i can offer the images
okay so i may not have any images right
now so i just leave this image playing
right now
okay and this script src i'll load it
only
before my body tag had closed it's
always a good practice to keeping this
script tag on the bottom of the body tag
always designed for good practice
now this is almost ready for me let me
check
okay so i can see
values
now it will go maximum nine that is how
we have given and minimum is one
start is the button which is not doing
anything but later on we can allow some
logic inside this
now we have to start working with our
main javascript tag
this is my amp.js and here onwards we
will use
some of the properties okay which i want
to initialize it so using var
game
start
equal to
initialize
second game speed
equal to
next game
area
equal to
null
game area context
equal to null
then
gave area width
game area
width
equal to
zero that is
integer value
game area height
game area
equal to 0 again
then solve it
cell width equal to 0
play score
equal to 0 again
next
snake equal to null
next snake food
equal to null
next snake direction
equal to
null
snake speed or else i can say speed size
speed size
equal to
zero
next we have a timer
equal to
so these number of properties
we've initialized
okay
now after that we will be writing a
function by saying function
name is called initialize
okay and here in initialized
we would like to use some of the
properties
first we are saying
game start equal to
document dot
get element by id
here i can give the value call
hash
game start let me put it in double
quotes
okay
start
now game speed now these are all
basically the values are there game
start game speed
these all values we have to take it
okay so we will be seeing these values
one by one so let me say that another
one that is called game speed
game speed equal to again
document dot
get element by id now we are passing
the game speed
[Music]
game speed
now
here
once again i take another point game
area
i say game
game area
here you have to give the value called
game area
okay so these values we have taken
now we'll be talking about called game
media context
dot
get context
okay
and in this game context we will be
using what type of context using 2d
okay because i want to have
the kind of 2d so
this is how the kind of environment we
want to set
next we talk about game area width
equal to just initialize to 400
next
game area height
equal to 600
now solve it
we are initializing with 20
next game area dot width
okay so game area
dot
width equal to
game area width
and then we define k media dot height
dot
equal to
game area height
so these are the values we are
initializing this
okay
now after that we have to start writing
the logic here i'm saying game start
game start
dot now we have to line uh which event
you would like to take so i will say on
click
on
click so when i basically click what
should happen so on click equal to
function
so what you want to write it here i am
saying this dot
this dot disabled
equal to
true
so i want to disable these values
and after that we want to call
another function inside this
but which function let's do that so here
we are saying function
start game
start
okay
and
here in start game
we want to define the initial score see
the initial score for the player will be
certainly zero so we say
player
score
equal to zero
after that
direction in which direction you want
the snake to move so we are saying snake
direction equal to
right
in the right direction
then speed size
the value of the variable which we have
defined so speed size equal to because
it will be accepting the value
from the text boxes or from the drop
down so it certainly will be string type
so we have to use percent
so we're using this option called power
sent and here we are using
game speed
dot
[Music]
value
okay so we are using this value game
speed dot value now here we would like
to calculate certain things what those
are first we are saying if
okay
what if condition
[Music]
see this function we are writing called
start game
because there are certain things which
you need to
make it
so like that we have to define it so
function initialize
we have started
okay and then after that we have written
all click within this
so this is what the on click we had and
there onwards we have to finish this
point
and after that we've started
start game and now we'll be writing the
logic for this so here we are saying if
we're using speed size
missing equal to nine
we basically initialize to what nine
here we say else if
speed size
is
zero
we say speed size
sorry
speed size
equal to 1
that means if it is less than 0 i will
be making it minimum to 1 if it is
greater than 9 i will be making it to 9
maximum
and that's it
okay
so after this else if condition
is getting closed
we are seeing speed size equal to
1
so here we just say snake
snake equal to
array so that is my array for me and
after that we are saying snake
dot push
because it needs to move ahead and here
we'll be pushing it towards
by saying
x
position
0
and
then the y
and here the y value will be what
celebrate that means how far it can go
so it will go within the width of this
application
okay so that's how exactly we would like
to make it
okay so here we have a call cell which
we have given here
after that what we have to do is
we have to define our own function
called
clear interval
and this clear interval perform any
logic whichever i would like to make it
okay so here after that snake dot push
value has been given
here i will be creating one more
function here
that's known as call
create food okay so here we're
saying create
food
so create food will be the function for
me now you might be thinking where this
function is but this function will be
declared soon within your application
but here first we are seeing the
function called clear interval
clear interval
with the timer
[Music]
okay whatever the timer will be passing
it
and after that
this clearing treble will be saying
timer
equal to
set interval
with this we are saying create game area
create
now
here in our application whatever the
value we are giving it that we need to
basically implement we are giving this
call create food is a function we are
calling after that we are calling this
clear
will
interval
just like in a typical function which is
there using this option called create
game area
so
this will be available to me on which
the value will be taken that
okay and then we will be telling you
how you can call this function create
food and how to create it first well so
we are talking about a functionality
called create game interval so this
create game
timer is the one which we have to create
it by our own so this function which we
are passing it after the saying set
interval
this function is not it there so we have
to basically go back and create this
function within my application
fine so what we will do is just
particular one we will try to comment it
for a time being
okay so here we have a call what create
interval
in this create interval will be
passing any parameters which we are
passionate about as a timer here and
here we are calling this call create
food
so here after that we'll be calling this
function called create food so let's go
and say
function create food
in this question create food let's go
and write a logic here
and what logic we want to write it in a
create food we say snake food
snake food equal to
and here in our currently basis we use
two direction x and y
we say in x we say
math
dot
around
and inside this
we say
math
dot
random
after this math.random function we have
to just take this calculation
and check the another parameter called
game area with
game
area width
minus
cell width the one which you are passing
it and here after that we'll be
performing the calculation by saying
celebrate
okay so this is for our x coordinate
similarly we would like to use for my y
coordinate also
now
math dot round round dot number game
area
game area height
but
here rather than using width we'll be
using height
minus
seventh let me give some space
divided by cell width
okay
so that's where exactly it's got closed
okay now here
our applications is now ready by calling
the function called create4
like that we'll be going to create
another function called create game area
let me go and create all the functions
first so we are saying function create
game area
create
game
area
there's another function for me
after this create game area there will
be another function i'm going to create
it
that is called control
function
control
okay after that we'll write one more
function called function
right score
there's another function available for
us control we have a call right score
there's another function which is going
to write it down here that is called
function
right score is done now we say create
square
create
square
this is another function
and finally we'll have a call change
direction
function
change
change
direction
so that's it so these many functions we
wanted to create it here in our system
well
we know very well that we have taken
this call create food grade food
function is already ready now now we're
going to talk about our next function
called create gain area and in this
great game area we are defining two
locations var
x direction and y direction so we say
uh a snake
x
equal to
snake the position we are taking is
called zero and we are saying dot x
for the x direction
we are saying var
snake
y
equal to
snake
position we are taking once again zero
and
dot okay so two directions we have taken
x direction and y direction
now here we are starting
gain
area
context dot
fill style that unit variable it is a
property
fill style equal to which color you want
to fill this up
so i'm saying hash white color
okay and then we are using this game
area context again
dot fill react
fill react
now keep the position values i'm saying
0 comma 0 comma
game area
game area width
comma
game area height
so we are basically filling the values
with color we want to use it called
stock style let me take this game area
context again
dot
stock style
stroke style
equal to now we give the other color
here
by saying hash
okay and then the next option called
same gave me the context dot stroke
react
stroke
react and here we pass the values again
zero comma
zero
comma
game area width
comma
game
area
height
so we're passing those values like that
and now after this we have to write a
logic of the directions
now see the when you talk about snake
game it move left right and center
up and down so now in this case we have
to increment the situations accordingly
so we say if
the snake direction
if the snake direction go to
right
then we say snake
x
plus plus
now
else if
also
same
let's copy this
snake direction
left
then what should happen
here we say
snake
x
minus minus
okay so we're taking like that let me
copy this again
now here
here we're taking about left right we
set down
so in this case this is snake
y
plus plus
and in this case
if it is up
let me say
snake
y minus minus
so these conditions we are taking it now
now here after this else if condition we
would like to take another if condition
now here in my if condition
we are
using some more lengthy statements
what's that we say
if
snake x
f snakes x
minus 1 or
snake x
double equal to
game
area
width which we have taken
divided by
salvage
okay or
we are taking this condition called
snake y
snake y double equal to
minus one
okay so we're giving this call minus one
or
snake y
stick by equal to
gain area height
to serve it
or
here we will take the another condition
here
yeah we will take the another condition
here call
we will have another function called
control
which we have
created some time back and inside this
control
it will take some parameters so what
those parameters we can pass okay we can
say
snake
x
comma
snake y
comma
third parameter will be
stick
so this could be my another function
okay
so here
we are passing the conditions just like
that
okay now here
this is
available to use a parenthesis
and here
we're writing the situation for right
score
which is so far the function is only
created not
described more so we're writing the
right score score will be written here
and here we are saying clear interval
because the timer will be stopped
okay and using game start
dot
disabled
equal to
false
and after that
return
that's it
so this is the logic for we have written
to this particular example
now we can use
another if more conditions here just to
check the behavior of my code if getting
your learning started is half the battle
what if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
well here we have finished this
game start dot disabled equal to false
and we returned
now going forward after this return
we would like to have another condition
for the snake x so we say if
snake x
if a snake x double equal to
snake food
dot x
okay snake foot vortex
ampersand perfect
snake
y
double equal to
snake
food dot
y
then in this case i will say
var new head
bar
new head sorry
var
new head equal to here
x colon
snake x
y
colon snake boy
snake x and y colon
snake
these options we are taking it
now
after that we are using this option
called player score
plus
equal to
speed size
and then we are calling
create food method again
and here after that we're using the else
condition
and in this else condition
we are saying var
new head
equal to
snake
dot pop
okay and we are saying new head
dot x
equal to snake x
and new head
dot y equal to
snake
y
so these values are basically
associating with your heads and after
that we are saying snake
dot unshift
and shift
snake dot and shift and here we are
passing this option called new head
that's it and after that we'll be
starting with our for loop by saying
for
var equal to
one i
i equal to zero
then
i is less than
snake dot
length
and
snake dot length
and once i
plus
plus
okay later on we just use the option
called
create
square
and in discrete square we are passing
snake
snake position
i
dot
x
comma
same
snake
dot y
that's it
so it's getting closed here and after
that we are calling the same option
with this snake food let me copy this
again
and here rather than
using this we can say snake food dot x
and snake foot dot y
okay so now this values has been added
into my code now it will start working
with your control
control needs to take three parameters
x y and the array so we are passing this
option call
control and in this control we are
taking x
comma y
comma
array
three parameters we are taking it later
on we are using this option called for
var
i equal to zero
i
is less than
array dot
length
and i
plus plus
and after that we'll be using this
option called if condition and here we
say
array
i
which value we are passing dot x
double equal to
x
ampersand time percent
here we say array
with a position called i
and in this we are saying dot y
and this position we are checking for
the y condition
for the y condition so it returns what
true
written
through
the condition
okay that is for if condition else
return was
false
now that's it now we are talking about
this option name called right score
this right score we have to use the game
area context
game
area context dot
font
equal to
here we'll be passing this situation
using 50 pixels
50 pixels and then sends
iphone
service
after that we're using call game media
context again let me copy this
take it again call game media context
dot
fill style equal to here i'll be using
another color now
so we say hash
okay
now after that we are saying once again
the game area context dot
fill
text
here we are saying
score
colon
and here we say
plus
player score whatever it is with game
area width
game area width
slash
2
minus
100
and then again
game area with
slash
so this is where exactly the right score
where the data will be actually written
okay next we'll be having this option
called create square and this great
square it takes two parameters one we're
talking about call x
second is taking y
and now here
we're using this game radio context
same
dot
fill style
equal to let me give the color
after this we're using call same gary
and text
game area text dot
fill react
here we are saying x
multiplied by
cell width comma
this is what
my great square is now we are left with
only one option that is known for change
direction
it's time to figure out this last
function called change direction
which takes one parameter called e
typically we talk about for
parameters now here we are passing this
option called workkeys
equal to e
dot
and
later on we want to say if
keys
equal to
40
okay
ampersand ampersand
is sneak direction
equal to
up
okay so here we say
snake direction
equal to
down so we are changing the directions
here
okay now let me try to copy this
[Music]
and here we use elsif
[Music]
four times
okay
so here we talk this
30 40 and here we say 39
and followed by 38
followed by 37. 39 38 27
and here we say up
let's change to what
left
down
right
here we say
right
up
left
the three options we have changed and
last but not least here
i will just use
window dot
on key down
equal to
change directions
and
window
dot
on load
okay equal to
initialize that's how exactly we want to
use now and this function what we have
defined in initialize
okay
so in this initialize
we are having this game start dot on
clicking and all so you have a call
start game now
this start game will be calling it here
okay so in start
we were called snake we have called
snake dot push
and after that we are calling
this function called what
create food clear interval and here we
say
timer equal to
here set clear interval and here
change
game area
slash
speed
size
let's say you want to use it
okay everyone so our code is almost
ready so we have this complete
javascript code ready with me
now it's time to basically use within my
html
just to check how it may behave
so in my html page i have written this
normal speed
number
game speed value
button start we will call game start
after that we have a call canvas where
we written id equal to call game area
dev classic to relative
and
that's it and here we have a call script
sr is equal to app.js
so that's it what we have written now
finally we would like to see how it may
look if i try to use in my browser let
me try to refresh
okay
i really do not see any changes in my
code
okay
despite i'm having this because
the css content is actually missing
okay because then only
my code really look
better
because if there is no css it wouldn't
really make
good towards my application
okay and i also want to have certain
images but those images we will take it
later on let me go back and try to bring
css into this picture now
so first of all
have this
index.html file with me
and here i want to use css so inside my
head tag
we want to use
link
real
equal to
style sheet
okay hr
equal to
app
dot
css
okay
now
here
in my css we want to offer certain
details
what those details i want to start
working with i will start with my body
part
body so we want to offer
the font family
so
font family maybe a little bit later on
i can use it first i want to use margin
margin 20 pixels
auto
later text
align
center
next font size
font size 150 pixels
also 150 percent
and here we want to say background
background image
since i do not have any image so i will
just leave it as a blank
okay so just otherwise i have to say url
and insert this url it gives some values
but i leave it as a blank because i do
not have any image i will say background
color
in this background color i can just use
white
after that height
i can just say 800 pixels
after that
background position
background position i want to use center
then background repeat
background repeat i want no repeat
then background size
okay let's see if there's an effect in
my
okay i see it's now
in the middle
better
now
inputs canvas we have to basically take
that here we talk about call input
okay in this input i say font size
font size may be optional i can
make it
but let me just say font size 100
percent
then text align
center then padding
i want to say five pixels
and
seven pixels
okay looks better now
well here after that i can use canvas
in this canvas
i want to see the background color
i just say write
after that border radius
border release i can say 20 pixels
then
shadow if i want to use it so i just say
box shadow
box shadow i can say 3 pixels
5 pixels
and six pixels
and the color is
black
let's check
awesome
so i can see here
[Music]
the
logic is there so shadow you can easily
see how it has been using
and
that's it and this div
i can say
div
dot relative
position
absolute
top
here i'm saying using 760 pixels
left
120 pixels
that's it
so this is where exactly
i program now when i say start
okay so there may be some error here
then they cannot set a property of call
on click
null
so this we can just check this into this
gamestop.online
let's check
anyways
we just try to fix that issue in a
while
but anyways we have our created css and
now going forward we'll be implementing
the rest of the logic within my code
okay everyone so we have changed some
names here because there was some value
was mismatched so we have basically
changed those values
with your properties and now when i try
to relaunch my application
by
this
index.html file
so now in my index.html file when i try
to add
so
it's just as usual same let me say start
and here you can see game start when i
go up you see like it's starting right
now
okay isn't this an amazing game right
now friends
okay that is the same game what you used
to play it earlier
okay where you can just change the
direction
go up and you can see the score 10 title
being placed here
that's it so this is where exactly the
look and feel of your game has been
taken
and you can just increase the speed
suppose if you just put a value call
what zero
by default set
whatever value you want to take it with
a start now you can see
based on that the speed can be justified
and the example can be developed
okay you can see the start button is
disabled because right now the user is
still going on unless the user game is
finished this one is not going to work
right
so like that you can see and
automatically this will be positioned
this is what's called food that is how
we have used in my example now called
app.js you can see we are using this
example name called food
create food so in create food of the
specific interval time this would be
automatically created and the snake will
eat and increase the size of the code
okay that's it and now the css has been
given if you want to add certain image
certainly you can add it otherwise this
is the first game which we can see how
it is running and giving you the better
example
and with that we've come to the end of
this video i hope you had fun building
these applications
if you have any doubts or queries let us
know in the comment section below
thank you for watching keep learning and
stay tuned for more from cynthia
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
you